Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 29. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe hier über die Raumfahrt und ja, in der heutigen Ausgabe hat es mich abermals an das ESOC der ESA, das Kontrollzentrum in Darmstadt, verschlagen und es dreht sich um Herschel, ein Weltraumteleskop, was seit einiger Zeit im Betrieb ist und um alle Aspekte der Technik und anderer Geheimnisse dieses Geräts zu ergründen, begrüße ich Micha, Micha Schmidt. Hallo. Ja, was ist eigentlich deine offizielle Arbeitsbezeichnung hier? Was steht auf der Visitenkarte?
Auf Neudeutsch, Spacecraft Operations Manager. Ich würde das bezeichnen als Leitenden Ingenieur für den Betrieb eines Satelliten, speziell dieses Weltraumteleskops Herschel.
Das heißt, du gehörst zu dem Operations Team des ESOC?
Genau, Flight Control Team. Das ist die Ansammlung von Ingenieuren, Technikern, die für den Betrieb des Satelliten im Orbit, nachdem er gestartet worden ist, verantwortlich sind.
Operations war ja hier auch schon mal ein dediziertes Thema. In der vierten Ausgabe habe ich mit Michelle Denise, der dann wahrscheinlich ein Kollege ist, gesprochen, über die ganzen Aspekte der Führung von Raumfahrzeugen, nachdem sie dann endlich mal gestartet sind. Heute wollen wir uns im Wesentlichen auf Herschel konzentrieren, Herschel, ich habe es schon gesagt, ist ein Weltraumteleskop. Was macht Herschel so besonders?
Herschel ist ein Weltraumteleskop, das im Infraroten beobachtet. Infrarot heißt, man beobachtet Wärmestrahlung. Das auf der anderen Seite heißt, dass die Instrumente, die Detektoren an Bord dieses Satelliten, dieses Raumschiffs, selber keine Eigentemperatur haben dürfen. Keine Eigentemperatur, das geht natürlich nicht. Jeder Körper hat eine Eigentemperatur. Aber die Detektoren, gewisse Komponenten dieser Instrumente müssen halt so weit runtergekühlt werden, wie es irgendwie geht. Und das bestimmt halt den Aufbau des Satelliten. Wie baut man so einen Satelliten, der das kann? Bestimmt aber auch zum Beispiel den Orbit, in den dieser Satellit geschickt wird, wenn man das am besten macht, dass er einfach schon passiv gekühlt ist, in dem er halt keiner Sonnenstrahlung und keiner Erdstrahlung ausgesetzt ist. Das ist schon eine technische Herausforderung, die für Herschel auf unwahrscheinlich clevere Art gelöst worden ist. Und das macht diese Mission auch besonders interessant. Die Mission ist anspruchsvoll im Betrieb, war anspruchsvoll in der Herstellung, wie man so einen Satelliten baut. Es ist ein sehr interessantes Projekt, das ich von einem, wo ich das Glück hatte, dieses Projekt von einer ziemlich frühen Phase schon zu betreuen und dann bis zum Start zu betreuen. Und ich habe mir auch vorgenommen, das bis zum Ende machen, weil ein Aspekt, auf den wir vielleicht später noch kommen, ist die beschränkte Lebensdauer, weil er halt auch aktiv gekühlt wird. Und da habe ich mir schon vorgenommen, den bis zum Schluss so mitzubekleiden.
Was ist denn so dein persönlicher Werdegang, der dich jetzt für dieses Projekt qualifiziert hat? Also mit welchem Ausbildungshintergrund bist du hier zu ESA gekommen?
Ich bin Diplom-Engineur für Raumfahrtechnik. Das habe ich studiert in Berlin, habe dann meinen Abschluss gemacht, habe eine Zeit lang an der Universität in Berlin noch gearbeitet.
Welche Universität macht das?
Das war die Technische Universität in Berlin und habe dann meinen Abschluss 1992 gemacht. Das war auch eine sehr interessante Zeit, weil, was ungewöhnlich ist, so was ungewöhnlich war und was eine riesengroße Chance und auch sehr viel Spaß gemacht hat, war, dass also der Professor, bei dem wir Satellitentechnik gehört haben, das war der Professor Renner, sich einfach gesagt hat, warum einfach reden, ja wir bauen einen Satelliten. Und das war also eine kleine Gruppe von Studenten, Assistenten, Tutoren und auch Studenten, die er betreut hat, die tatsächlich dann einen Satelliten gebaut haben. Der wurde dann sozusagen Huckepack mit einem anderen Satelliten auf der Areane gestartet, auch mit einem ESA-Satelliten, EAS war das damals. Und das hat mich noch ein bisschen an der Universität gehalten. Und nach einer Jahrzeit hatte ich dann gedacht, okay, ich möchte mich mal ein bisschen weiterentwickeln und weiter bewerben und hatte mich dann bei der ESA auch direkt hier bei der ESOC beworben auf eine Stelle und hatte dann also quasi das Glück, auch mehr oder weniger direkt von der Universität, nach meiner Universitätsausbildung, dann direkt hier bei der Europäischen Weltraumbehörde anfangen zu können.
Was hat denn dieser Satellit gemacht?
Der Satellit hat eine Lücke gefüllt. Das war ein Tubsatiste. Er hat Store und Forward gemacht. Das heißt, wir konnten also jetzt nicht unsere eigene Mission bestimmen und sagen, wir machen jetzt irgendwas und müssen unbedingt einen hohe elliptischen Orbit, sondern wir mussten erst mal wissen, ja was bietet sich denn an? Wie kommen wir denn überhaupt in Weltraum? Und da war halt dieses Konzept, das angeboten wurde von Ariane Spass und von der ESA, dass man halt anstelle von Gewichten, die quasi auf einer Struktur unter dem Satelliten, der Hauptlast, also richtigen Satelliten, in dem Falle ERS, Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, statt da Gewichte mit zu pflegen, dass man einfach dann Amateuren, in Anführungsstrichen, so wie Universitäten, die TU Berlin war nicht die einzige, anbietet, kleine Satelliten in der Größenordnung von 30 cm mal 30 cm mit einem geringen Gewicht auf diese Struktur zu packen. Das war also quasi ein Ring unter dieser Sylderstruktur, auf den hatte man dann zum Beispiel bei diesem Start erst zwei, sechs Satelliten gepackt, einer davon wieder der Tub-Sat.
Und unter welcher Struktur? Sylda?
Sylda, ja. Was ist das genau für ein Ring? Das ist quasi der Adapter, mit dem der Hauptglas oder der Satellit auf der Rakete befestigt wird. Und wir mussten uns also danach richten, was ist denn der Orbit, den man erreichen könnte. Und für diesen Flug war das halt eine erdnahe Umlaufbahn, typischerweise für Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, weil das halt der Start für ERS war. Und da haben wir uns gedacht, was kann man damit machen? Und was wir damit gemacht haben, wir haben einfach so gesagt sozusagen herkömmliche Walkie-Talkies ausgeschlachtet und haben damit ein System entwickelt, mit dem man kurze Nachrichten, so in einer Größenordnung von einer SMS mit 256 Zeichen, ablegen kann auf dem Satelliten. Wenn jemand eine kleine Bodenstation hatte, was auch nichts weiter war als ein modifiziertes Walkie-Talkie, konnte der, wenn er die Überflugszeiten wusste, die Nachricht empfangen, die auf diesem Satelliten abgelegt war, und eine eigene Nachricht hochschicken. Und das haben wir auch angeboten. Das wurde auch angenommen. Wir hatten zum Beispiel damals was angeboten, dem, wie heißt er denn jetzt, Arvind, da muss ich nachher nochmal nachgucken. Die Telekommunikation zum Beispiel um die Pole. Ich meine, man hat Inwasatt und so, wo die Telekommunikation für Schiffe, für Schiffsverkehr oder so was abgedeckt ist. Aber um die Pole, da gab es eigentlich ein Loch. Und für solche Abenteuer, das war also der Begleiter mit dem Messmer, dem Südpol. Arvid Fuchs, genau. Dankeschön.
Ich war jetzt gerade in einem anderen Namensraum unterwegs.
Und der hatte tatsächlich auch eins von unseren Geräten dabei, als er, nachdem die Nordwest-Passage frei war, mit seinem Schiff, mit seinem historischen Schiff, also quasi den Nordpol umrundet hat und hat also auch die Nachrichten dann hochgeschickt und seine Heimatbasis informiert hat. Das war also ganz interessant. Vor allen Dingen war das interessant als, wie soll man das sagen, als Training für Studenten. Das ist ja angewandte Raumfahrtechnik. Wo kriegt man die Gelegenheit, da sowas zu machen? Dafür war ich damals sehr dankbar, dass wir sowas machen konnten.
Zumal er ja wahrscheinlich dann auch der ganze Schnaß noch mit dabei war, dass man ja dann, auch wenn es quasi nur so eine zusätzliche Last ist, man muss ja dann auch alles nachweisen, dass es den Rest nicht stört, nicht gefährdet, dass es allen möglichen Anforderungen genügt etc. Und das ist ja dann, glaube ich, ein extrem lehrreicher Prozess an der Stelle, um überhaupt das mal gesagt zu bekommen, wie lang die Liste ist, die man dann berücksichtigen muss.
Das ist richtig. Wir mussten Nachweise erbringen, wir mussten im Reihenraum gehen und es durfte nichts ausgasen. Wir mussten natürlich verifizieren und bestätigen und testen, dass der Mechanismus sich mit dem den Satelliten quasi von der Struktur trennt, also die Trennung von der Rakete, dass der sich nicht selber auslöst und so weiter.
Aber hat dann geklappt.
Das hat geklappt, der war unterwegs und da gab es auch noch Nachfolge.
30 Zentimeter, also quasi so ein kleinerer Fußball, der dann einfach so durch die Gegend fliegt. War das jetzt eine mentale oder eine konkrete technische Ausschlachtung von Walkie Talkies? Also hat man wirklich die Dinge auseinander geschraubt und dann diese Komponenten verwendet oder hat man sich quasi im Funktionsprinzip orientiert und dasselbe nochmal gebaut?
Nein, nein. Wir haben also richtig auch die Hardware benutzt von diesen Walkie Talkies und ja, richtig physikalisch ausgeschlachtet, neu zusammengelötet. Wie hoch flog der dann? Wie gesagt, die Erdumlaufbahn war halt gegeben vor der Haupt-Nutzlast von IS und das ist eine typische Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten. Erdbeobachtungsumlaufbahn, die kreisförmig in ungefähr 900 Kilometer Höhe ist.
Und dann über die Pole.
Und dann über die Pole. Und das macht das auch für die Kommunikation interessant, weil der Satellit halt alle 100 Minuten, also 14 Mal am Tag ungefähr, vorbei kommt. Und dann kann man halt Nachrichten schicken und Nachrichten empfangen.
Ja, da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass man dann aber auch wirklich schon gepolt ist, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, für dieses Thema. Ja, kommen wir doch wieder zurück zu unserem eigentlichen Thema. Als du dann hier beim ESOC angefangen hast, war dann gleich Herschel das gleich das erste Thema?
Nein, das war Herschel noch in weiter Ferne. Die ESA hat also quasi erst seinen Einstand gehalten mit Infrarot-Beobachtungen, mit einem anderen Projekt. Also mein erstes Projekt war das Infrared Space Observatory ISO. Dass 1995 dann gestartet worden ist und dass wir auch zweieinhalb Jahre betrieben haben dann in Spanien. Wir sind dann für den Betrieb dieses Satelliten nach Spanien gegangen. Danach sind wir wieder nach Darmstadt zurückgekommen mit dem Thema. Und man könnte also quasi sagen, ISO war der Vorreiter von Herschel. Und das heißt also, die Beobachtungen und die wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse, die man mit dem Infrarot-Space-Observatori quasi erreicht hat, erlangt hat, gaben Grund und haben das Ganze auch gepusht, Grund genug dafür, einen noch genaueren Satelliten, noch genauere Instrumente zu entwickeln und Sachen, die ISO entdeckt hatte, noch viel genauer zu erforschen.
Was waren denn das für Erkenntnisse? Also was hat man denn so aus dem ISO-Projekt heraus gewonnen und was war so die ursprüngliche Intention überhaupt mit dem Projekt?
Also erstmal, warum baut man einen Satelliten, der in den Weltraum geschossen wird, um irgendwas zu beobachten, was im Weltraum ist? Man kann ja einfach in den Sternenhimmel gucken und sieht Sterne oben am Himmel. Also das Spektrum der elektromagnetischen Wellen, wenn man sich das wie einen Filter vorstellen kann, wird gefiltert von der Atmosphäre auf der Erde. Das heißt, es gibt also verschiedene Wellenlängen, die durchkommen. Das ist sichtbare Licht. Sonst hätten wir keine Augen, sonst hätten wir nicht Augen entwickelt, um uns zu orientieren, sondern ein anderes Organ. Aber es gibt auch Wellenlängen, die rausgefiltert werden. Das infrarote Licht wird rausgefiltert, ganz einfach, weil die Atmosphäre eine Eigentemperatur hat. Aus diesem Grunde baut man einen Satelliten, der über der Atmosphäre ist und der also ohne irgendwelche Störungen die Signale wahrnehmen kann. Was war nochmal die Frage jetzt?
Naja, was sozusagen die Erkenntnisse waren, die jetzt konkret bei ISO dann auch anfallen. Also ISO war ja ein Projekt, was um die Erde herum rotiert ist, richtig?
Das ist richtig.
Bei Herschel ist es ja ein bisschen anders.
Bei Herschel ist es anders. Das war auch ein Lernprozess.
Ich meine, der Infrarot, die Sonne ist ja auch weiter draußen durchaus da. Ich meine, die Atmosphäre hat eine eigene Temperatur, aber man ist ja jetzt auch im Weltall nicht vor Temperatur gefeit. Wie hat sich den ISO vor dem Einfluss der Sonne geschützt?
Das ist richtig und das ist genau die interessante Frage. Und das ist auch einer von diesen Lernprozessen, wenn man sich die beiden Satelliten nebeneinander angucken würde. Jeder Körper im Weltraum hat eine Temperatur. Temperatur ist eine Eigenschaft eines Körpers. Man sagt, im Weltraum ist es kalt. Es gibt einfach keine Temperatur, wenn da kein Körper ist, der irgendwie Stralung absorbieren kann und dann Stralung abgeben kann. Die Umlaufbahn von ISO war also eine typische Umlaufbahn, die man damals gewählt hat und die man auch machen konnte mit den Raketen, die damals zur Verfügung stand. Und war eine hocheleptische Umlaufbahn. In heutiger Sicht würde man sagen, es ist ein Kompromiss. Man hat also eine hocheleptische Umlaufbahn gewählt, die an dem höchsten Punkt weit genug von der Erde entfernt war, sodass die störenden Einflüsse von der Erdstrahlung selber auch minimiert waren. Wir sind im Sonnensystem, man kriegt die Strahlung der Sauna ab. Je näher man an der Erde ist, kriegt man auch Erdstrahlung ab. Und nicht nur das. Dadurch, dass sich der Satellit quasi um die Erde bewegt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das so bildlich vorstellen könnt, da gibt es Momente, da gibt es Situationen, wo der Satellit also quasi zwischen Sonne und Erde durch muss. Und dann hat man also die Erde auf der einen Seite vom Satelliten und die Sonne auf der anderen Seite von dem Satelliten. Das heißt also, man kriegt auf jeden Fall Strahlung ab. Also das typische Design, also eine Sache, die gemeinsam, die die ESO und Herschel gemeinsam haben, ist das sogenannte Sonnenschutzschild, das Solar Shield, das den Satellit von der Sonnenstrahlung quasi, vor der Sonnenstrahlung schützen muss. Das ist also wirklich, man kann sich das vorstellen, das ist ein Teleskop, also ein langgezogener Körper, dieser Satellit. Und auf der einen Seite ist es einfach nur ein Panel, eine Platte, die den Satellit von der Sonnenstrahlung abschirmt. Und da packt man natürlich auch die Solarzahlen drauf, damit Energie erzeugt wird, hat man quasi zwei Vögel mit einem Stein erschlagen. Bei ESO war das jetzt so gewesen, dass der Satellit, was auch bei der Herschel der Fall ist, nie mit der anderen Seite, also mit der Seite, die nicht von diesem Schutzschild, das fest auf dem Satellit montiert ist, ausgesetzt ist, dass der Satellit sich nie mit der anderen Seite zur Sonne drehen darf. Bei ESO hatte man diesen Kompromiss gemacht, wenn der Satellit zwischen Erde und Sonne durch muss, dann ist die Sonne immer auf der Seite von dem Sonnenschutzschild. Aber manchmal kann es sein, dass die Erde auf der anderen Seite ist und dann kriegt der Satellit quasi Wärmestrahlung ab. Elbedo oder Erd-Eigenstrahlung. Wenn man die beiden Satelliten sich nebeneinander anguckt, ist das auch reflektiert einfach in dem Design und in dem sogenannten Coating, das heißt der Oberfläche von dem Satelliten. ISO war, wie man das von manchen Satelliten kennt, herkömmlichen, wie man sich einen Satelliten vorstellt oder auch zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, von dem Shuttle, die Bay, alles ist irgendwie weiß ausgekleidet. Das heißt, die Oberfläche von ISO war weiß. Das ist ein guter Kompromiss, weil weiße Farbe nicht so viel Strahlung absorbiert. Es strahlt auch nicht so viel ab, aber es absorbiert nicht so viel Strahlung.
Da kennt man ja auch von schwarzen Autos in der Sonne, die sich dann halt auftanken mit Hitze.
Aber Schwarz hat auch gute Abstrahlung, also Eigenschaften, um Strahlung abzustrahlen. Das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt Herschel anguckt, bei Herschel hat man den Sprung gemacht und hat also in der Zwischenzeit halt diese Satellitenbahnen nicht um einen Planeten, also nicht um unsere Erde, sondern um den sogenannten Lagrange-Point entdeckt. Und der Vorteil davon ist, man hat sich einen Lagrange-Point 2 ausgesucht. Also wenn man jetzt das Gravitationsfeld der Erde und der Sonne überlagern will, hat ein cleverer Mensch, also der Lagrange, ausgerechnet, dass es also fünf Punkte gibt, wo sich quasi die Anzügungskräfte aufheben. Das sind stabile Punkte. Wenn man sich den Punkt L2 anguckt, dann ist es der Punkt, der auf der sonnenabgewandten Seite der Erde ist. Also wenn man sich das in einer Linie vorstellt, dann ist auf der einen Seite die Sonne, als nächstes kommt die Erde und dahinter ist dieser L2. Und da sieht man direkt den Vorteil für einen Infrarot-Satelliten wie Herschel.
Also was heißt stabil? Das heißt, die Anziehungskraft von Erde und Sonne heben sich auf.
Ja, so muss man sich das vorstellen. Das kann man sich sehr gut vorstellen, wenn man sich L1 anguckt. Das kann jeder sofort verstehen.
Weil es auf der Erde und Sonne liegt sozusagen.
Genau.
Das heißt, man ist so weit von der Erde weg, dass die Erde einen genauso sehr anzieht, wie es die Sonne tut, obwohl die Sonne noch sehr viel weiter weg ist, aber die ist natürlich auch größer.
Das ist ein bisschen vereinfacht dargestellt. Man muss sehen, dass das System sich auch bewegt. Und ich helfe mir auch. Meine Vorstellungskraft versagt auch. Man muss sich das vorstellen, dass die Überlagerung dieses Systems, quasi Erde und Sonne, die sich bewegen, Punkte erzeugen von potenziellen Minima und potenziellen Maxima. Es gibt also Punkte, die absolut stabil sind. Das wäre ein sogenanntes potenzielles Minimum. Das muss man sich wie ein Tal vorstellen, wo eine Kugel reinfällt. Aber einige von diesen fünf Punkten sind auch potenzielle Maxima. Das heißt, wenn man auf der Spitze eines Hügels steht und wieder rechts nach links angeschubst wird, dann fällt man auch nicht runter, man bleibt stabil stehen. Man muss sich das auch so vorstellen, dass der Satellit von der Erde und von der Sonne angezogen wird, sich aber auf einer Bahn bewegt. Und die Erde bewegt sich auch auf einer Bahn. Deswegen kann man sagen, dass dieser L2-Punkt stabil ist. Stabil heißt, dass man die Geschwindigkeit des Satelliten, der sich an diesem Punkt befindet, nicht groß ändern muss. Er wird weiter auf einer Umlaufbahn bleiben. Der ist also quasi eine Umlaufbahn, auch um die Sonne zusammen mit der Erde ist.
Das heißt, die Idee war, man hat mit ISO erst mal mit Infrarot-Teleskopie im Weltraum experimentiert. Das war die erste Infrarot-Mission der ESA. War das auch die erste Infrarot-Mission überhaupt? Nein, das war es nicht.
Nein, das gab es vorher schon. Die Amerikaner hatten schon andere Missionen gehabt.
Aber man hat gesagt, okay, alles klar, jetzt hier eine große Ellipse um die Erde herum. Das ist so ein bisschen gewollt, aber nicht gekonnt, weil man ja dann trotzdem die ganze Zeit immer wieder an der Erde vorbeifliegt. Und es ist einfach nicht optimal. Verstecken wir uns doch lieber gleich hinter der Erde. Dann sehen wir diese Sonne nie und befinden uns einfach die ganze Zeit schon mal im Dunkeln.
Also, wie gesagt, es ist ein Lernprozess. Ich meine, ESA hat schon Sinn gemacht, so wie man das damals gemacht hat. Wie gesagt, wir haben zweieinhalb Jahre beobachtet mit diesem Konzept. Und das war ein Lernprozess. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Sonne und die Erde jetzt immer auf derselben Seite des Satelliten sind. Das heißt, wieder das Prinzip, da ist auf jeden Fall dieses Schutzschild. Und das Schutzschild schützt den Satelliten von der Strahlung der Sonne, die sonst die Komponenten, die kalt gehalten werden sollten, aufwärmt. Aber gleichzeitig hat man halt das Glück, dass die Erde und auch der Mond genau auf derselben Seite sind. Und es wird also nie passieren, wie es bei uns passiert ist, dass die Erde wieder auf der anderen Seite ist und da dann auch den Satelliten anstrahlt. Das sieht man auch. Ich hatte eben von der Farbe gesprochen. Das ist auch eine simple Sache, aber es ist funktioniert. Wie gesagt, Schwarz ist auch sehr gut darin, Energie abzustrahlen. Wenn man sich Herschel anguckt, dann ist auf der einen Seite wieder dieses Schutzschild, mit den Solarzellen, und auf der anderen Seite sieht es aus, als ob der Satelliten nicht fertig wäre. Aber es ist alles Schwarz und eine hohe Struktur. Das heißt also, allein durch die Wahl der Oberfläche, der Oberflächenfarbe, hat man eine passive Kühlung erreicht. Also die eine Seite wird ständig von der Sonne beschehen, die andere Seite wird nie von irgendetwas beschehen. Wir sehen nur den Weltraum mit den Sternen. Und alle anderen Himmelskörper in unserem Sonnensystem sind so weit entfernt. Und dann eine Rolle zu spielen. Und auf der anderen Seite, durch die schwarze Farbe, strahlt es also quasi maximal ab. Also jede eigene Temperatur, die übertragen wird durch die Struktur oder so, kann auch nach hinten in den Weltraum abgestrahlt werden. Und allein durch diesen Trick erreicht man schon in der Struktur selber, die dann das aktive Kühlsystem beinhaltet, schon niedrige Temperaturen. Temperaturen in der Größenordnung von 80 Kelvin.
Da muss ich aber noch mal ein paar Sachen hinterfragen und zusammenfassen. Also dieser L2-Punkt, der wurde jetzt primär gewählt wegen seiner... Also wie weit ist er entfernt von der Erde?
Der ist ungefähr 1,5 Millionen Kilometer entfernt von der Erde.
So. Und befindet sich quasi immer... Also wenn man sich dort befindet, dann hat man zwischen sich und der Sonne immer die Erde.
Das ist richtig.
Aber jetzt nicht in dem Mal, ich meine bei 1,5 Millionen Kilometern ist die Erde jetzt nicht mehr so groß, dass man irgendwie im Schatten wäre. Oder ist man da im Schatten in irgendeiner Form? Oder ist das einfach nur ein stabiler Punkt?
Nein, das ist auch richtig und sehr gut mitgedacht. Man geht natürlich nicht zu diesem L2-Punkt, weil der Erdschatten würde die Sonne verdunkeln und man hätte kein Licht auf den Solarpaneel. Den Erdschatten vermeidet man, weil es auch ein Wort dafür gibt, das nennt man Eclipse. Wenn also ein Himmelskörper zwischen den Satelliten und die Sonne kommt, sei es der Mond oder sei es die Erde, dann hat man eine Eclipse. Das heißt, man kann keine Energie generieren. Das heißt, der Satellit befindet sich nicht, das war einfach eine Vereinfachung, der befindet sich nicht auf diesem L2-Punkt, sondern es ist noch komplizierter, er befindet sich quasi auf einer stabilen Umlaufbahn um diesen fiktiven Punkt. Das ist also eine clevere Geschichte, sich so etwas auszudenken und wie gesagt, es war ein Lernprozess, der auch an der ESA hier vollzogen worden ist, auch von Mission Analysis. Ich glaube, mit den Leuten habt ihr auch schonmal gesprochen oder hast du auch schonmal gesprochen. Einfach so etwas zu erfinden und zu sagen, können wir das nicht nutzen. Man kann auch nicht von Umlaufbahn sprechen, sondern man muss sich das eher so vorstellen, wie eine Lisa-Yu-Figur. Tatsächlich ist es so, wir haben ja mit diesem Start, das war vor zwei Jahren 2009 im Mai, haben wir nicht nur Herschel hochgeschickt, sondern wir hatten noch den Schwester-Satelliten hochgeschickt, Planck. Die beiden wurden zusammen entwickelt, haben auch große Gemeinsamkeiten für das Service-Material, also für diesen Bus von den Satelliten, nicht Instrumente. Die wissenschaftliche Aufgabe ist eine ganz andere, aber die Entwicklung dieses eigentlichen Satellitenbusses weist viele Gemeinsamkeiten auf. Und dieser Schwester-Satellit befindet sich tatsächlich in einer Lisa-Yu-Figur um diesen L2-Punkt mit einer sehr großen Amplitude. Das heißt, die Ausmaße sind auch so, das muss ich dir vorstellen. Also L2 ist 1,5 Millionen Kilometer entfernt von der Erde. Und da macht man einen Orbit auf einer Lisa-Yu-Figur um diesen Punkt, der eine Amplitude, also eine Entfernung, hat von 400.000 Kilometern. Das ist der Herschel-Orbit. Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
400.000. Das heißt, man kommt der Erde dann zwischendurch auch immer wieder recht nahe.
Nein, das ist natürlich in derselben Ebene die Senkrecht ist zu der Linie. Satellit, Erde, Sonne. Und, entschuldigung, das war nicht der Herschel-Orbit, sondern das war der Planck-Orbit. Herschel-Orbit ist 800.000 Kilometer. Man muss sich das also vorstellen. Da ist die Erde, die Linie Sonne, Erde, Satellit. Und senkrecht dazu in einer Ebene fliegt dieser Satellit um diesen fiktiven Punkt.
Um diesen Punkt herum.
Und er auszilliert also nicht nur, wie soll man das sagen, jetzt in Richtung des Sonnensystem Nordpol und Südpol, sondern er auszilliert auch ein bisschen in die Richtung Erde. Aber nicht so, dass er der Erde wieder nahe kommt. Also wir haben Entfernung, also während es hängt von der Jahreszeit ab, weil der Satellit bewegt sich natürlich sehr langsam um diesen fiktiven Punkt. Jahreszeit stimmt auch nicht, sondern einfach auf dieser Bahn kommt er der Erde mal ein bisschen näher und geht mal ein bisschen wieder weg, weil er auszilliert auch in die Richtung von der Erde weg und zu der Erde hin.
Wenn man jetzt, okay, also man befindet sich an diesem Punkt, weil dieser Punkt gibt einem eine gewisse Stabilität und mehr oder weniger einen konstanten Abstand zur Erde, was ja dann auch für die Kommunikation nicht unerheblich ist. Man hätte ihn ja auch irgendwo hinschicken können und dann wäre er so in den Tiefen des Alts. Aber es geht ja, ich meine, beim Teleskop würde man ja meinen, dass eigentlich so ein stabiler Punkt relativ wichtig wäre, also dass man wirklich auch still steht. Aber das Ding steht ja eigentlich gar nicht still. Das zittert ja, zittert ja die ganze Zeit rum.
Oh nein, zittern ist ganz verboten. Nein, also da müssen wir unterscheiden, wie der Satellit sich auf einer Bahn bewegt, sei es jetzt um die Erde um oder einen Punkt. Aber zittern geht auch in die Richtung, wie stabil ist der Satellit und wie stabil kann er in eine Richtung gucken. Und das ist auch ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wichtiger Punkt für Herschel, die Genauigkeit, weil der Herschel ist ein Teleskop. Das alles hört sich jetzt sehr dynamisch an, ist aber, wie soll man das sagen, also der Satellit...
Weltraumdimension geradezu träge.
Ja, der Satellit bewegt sich kaum. Also Dopplermessungen, die man macht, so die Entfernung, der Satellit sich von der Erde weg bewegt, die man auch benutzt, um die Bahn zu bestimmen. Diese Doppelunterschiede sind sehr gering. Und es ist, wie soll man das jetzt sagen, Stabilität ist ein guter Punkt. Also was wir damit geschaffen haben, indem wir so einen Orbit oder so eine Umlaufbahn gewählt haben, ist gerade Stabilität in einer anderen Hinsicht. Dadurch, dass wir also quasi an diesem Punkt den Satelliten betreiben, der sich sehr langsam bewegt. Der nächste Punkt auf der Umlaufbahn zur Erde ist ungefähr 1,2 Millionen Kilometer, der weit entfernteste 1,7 Millionen Kilometer. Aber innerhalb von einem halben Jahr bewegt sich das. Aber wir haben dadurch eine Kondition geschaffen, dass wir den Satelliten quasi alle 24 Stunden einmal sehen. Wenn wir jetzt eine Erdumlaufbahn sich ausgesucht hätte, wie es andere Teleskope haben, zum Beispiel XMM Integral, die auch hier von der ESOC betrieben werden, ist das alles noch viel dynamischer, weil die Erdumlaufbahn muss ja nicht unbedingt eine Periode von 24 Stunden haben. Und dann muss man Bodenstation finden, um diesen Satelliten zu betreiben. Der Satellit bewegt sich mit einer relativen Geschwindigkeit zur Erdoberfläche. Die Erde dreht sich drunter weg. Das heißt, es ist also ein dynamischer Prozess, um jetzt festzustellen, welche Bodenstation kann ich benutzen, um diesen Satelliten zu betreiben, von welcher Bodenstation wird er abgelöst und so weiter. Und das ist immer sehr verschieden. Je nachdem, der Satellit hat eine Periode von 57 Stunden, die Erde dreht sich 24 Stunden, und dann kommt die neue Bodenstation ins Sichtfeld und so weiter. Bei Herschel und bei Planck ist das also quasi wunderbar. Man kann den Satelliten quasi immer zur selben Tageszeit mit derselben Bodenstation beobachten. Nicht beobachten, sondern Datenaustauschen.
Was war denn jetzt sozusagen das wichtigste Kriterium? Ich bin mir jetzt noch nicht so sicher, ob wir das schon so rausgearbeitet haben, dass dieser Lagrange-Punkt und diese spezielle Umlaufbahn herumkreisen. Was war das Hauptargument dafür? Man hätte ja auch genauso gut L1 nehmen können, der jetzt zwischen Erde und Sonne liegt. Da hätte man ja im Prinzip genau dieselben Späßchen machen können. Warum L2?
L1 hätte man auch nehmen können, wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, wie das mit Bodenstationenkontakt ist und alle 24 Stunden einmal. Aber was wir vorher erwähnt haben, ist ja der Thermalaspekt. Man hat die störenden Größen, die Erde, die Sonne und der Mond, den Satelliten wirklich kalt zu halten. Alle auf einer Seite von dem Satelliten.
Wenn man sonst die Erde auf der einen Seite hätte und auch bei 1,5 Millionen Kilometer wäre die Erde immer noch zu warm?
Sie wäre immer noch zu warm, nicht im Sinne von den Satelliten selber aufwärmen. Aber was wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden müssen, ist auf die Erde zu gucken mit dem Teleskop. Das wäre also quasi das Ende dieser Kryogenen, dieser gekühlten Mission.
Also Herschel ist sozusagen die selbst gewählte Frostbeule im Universum. Versucht einfach Infrarotstrahlung zu messen. Und man hat versucht, einen Punkt zu finden, der eben das Optimum bietet aus Kalt leicht zu kontaktieren. Und hat sich dann eben auf L2 eingeschossen und diese spezielle Bewegung um diesen L2-Punkt herumgefunden, der eben eine gewisse Distanzstabilität zur Erde gewährleistet.
Das ist also, wie gesagt, wenn wir wieder ISO vergleichen wollen mit Herschel, wie gesagt, ein Lernprozess. Wir lernen auch dazu. Es ist ein Riesenfortschritt auch für unsere Aufgaben, die wir machen. Ich bin kein Wissenschaftler, sondern ich bin also Ingenieur, der den Satelliten betreibt. Bei ISO war es tatsächlich so, dass wir auch weit weg von der Erde kommen wollten. Deswegen war das eine hocheleptische Bahn. Wenn der Satelliten auf dem weitesten entfernten Punkt der Erde war, hat er beobachtet. Aber während einer gewissen Zeit, wenn er der Erde immer näher kann und dann auf dem Perigeeum an der Erde vorbeifliegt, also am erstnächsten Punkt, mussten die Beobachtungen gestoppt werden. Und der Satellit wurde in einen gewissen Modus geschickt, der einen ganz bestimmten Fahrt, wo das Teleskop mit seiner Öffnung hingucken kann, so beschreibt, dass er immer am weitesten entfernt ist von der Erde und von der Sonne. Also nicht der Satellit physikalisch selber, sondern da, wo das Teleskop hinschaut. Das heißt also, das war auch eine 24-Stunden-Bahn, man hätte auch eine andere Löpse nehmen können. Aber alle 24 Stunden musste man für drei Stunden quasi die Beobachtung unterbrechen. Das ist ein ganz klarer Vorteil von Herschel. Wir beobachten rund um die Uhr 24 Stunden, weil wir einfach diese Konstellation nicht haben. Der Satellit eins ruhig auf seiner Umlaufbahn L2 24 Stunden lang beobachten kann.
Ja, wir haben es schon erwähnt. Herschel hat auch noch einen Schwester-Satelliten Planck.
Genau.
Was haben die beiden gemeinsam und was haben sie nicht gemeinsam? Also sind beides Weltraumteleskope?
Ein Planck ist kein Teleskop. Also Planck ist ein Instrument, ein Satellit, der den Himmel abscannen soll. Also im Gegensatz zum Teleskop, Herschel, Haiso, Hubble, Teleskope sind tatsächlich Fernkleser sozusagen, mit denen man in eine Richtung guckt und die eine hohe Stabilität brauchen, in diese Richtung zu gucken. Je ruhiger man das Fernrohr hält, desto besser ist das Bild, das man sieht. Das sind also sogenannte drei-Achsen- stabilisierte Satelliten, die mit einer hohen Genauigkeit für längere Zeit in eine Richtung gucken müssen. Planck hat die Aufgabe, den Himmel abzuscannen. Also Planck rotiert mit ungefähr einer Umdrehung pro Minute langsam und beobachtet im Mikrowellenbereich einfach die Hintergrundstrahlung von unserem Universum. Und die Aufgabe von Planck ist eine ganz andere. Also Herschel ist quasi ein Instrument für die Astronomen. Und Planck ist ein Instrument für die Physiker, die mehr Wissen erreichen wollen über den Ursprung des Universums. Man will also, indem man diese Signale, diese Mikrowellenbeobachtungen, also diese Unregelmäßigkeiten im Mikrowellenhintergrund, indem man die vermisst, möchte man Aussagen treffen über die ganz, ganz frühe Zeit, als unser Universum entstanden ist, kurz nach dem Urknall. Und das sind also die Unterschiede. Während Herschel 3-Achsen stabilisiert ist, ist Planck ein langsamer Spinner, so wie wir sagen. Also er dreht sich langsam. Und da sollte man eigentlich nicht meinen, dass die Entwicklung dieser beiden Satelliten gemeinsam betrieben wurde, es um Kosten zu sparen. Aber das ist tatsächlich so. Also während die Instrumente, also der Teil des Satelliten, den wir Nutzlast nennen, die Instrumente, also mit dem Teleskop vorne drauf, das Teleskop von Planck sieht auch ganz anders aus. Also die Anordnung dieser Instrumente ist ganz anders dediziert für diese Aufgabe, die er hat. Wenn man sich dagegen allerdings diesen Bus, ich nenne das jetzt Bus, wir nennen das Service-Modul, anguckt, also der Satellit, der Teil des Satelliten, der die Instrumente mit Strom versorgen muss, der die Lageregelung machen muss, also Lageregelung für den Herschel, wenn wir in eine Richtung gucken, die Lageregelung für den Planck langsam spinnen, Datenverarbeitung, die Daten weiterleiten, einsammeln von den Instrumenten auf den Recorder packen und dann zur gegebenen Zeit runterspielen. Diese Kompetente, dieses Service-Modul, ist zu 95 Prozent gleich, sollte man nicht meinen, oder sogar noch, also eine Zahl kann ich gar nicht nennen. Und dadurch hat man Kosten gespart.
Weil halt beide sich am selben Ort befinden und von daher eben mit denselben Größen arbeiten müssen an der Stelle.
Das hat jetzt gar nichts damit zu tun, dass sie sich am selben Ort befinden, die könnten auch in anderen Orten sein. Das ist einfach so, dass man eine clevere Auswahl von den verschiedenen Komponenten gemacht hat, die man braucht. Also man könnte jetzt zum Beispiel ganz banal sagen, also Datenverarbeitung an Bord der Satelliten, Daten einsammeln, aufzeichnen, verteilen, runterfucken auf die Erde, das kann ja bei allen Satelliten gleich aussehen. Tut es nicht, weil es gibt auch verschiedene Abstände zur Erde, verschiedene Anforderungen. Aber das kann bei den Satelliten gleich sein. Aber ein Lageregelungssystem, warum soll das zu 95 Prozent gleich sein zwischen Herschel und Planck? Das hat man aber trotzdem gemacht. Das heißt, man hat also Komponenten ausgesucht und die quasi so gebaut und entwickelt, dass die beiden Aufgaben gerecht werden. Das heißt also, der Sternsensor an Bord von Herschel und Planck, das ein wichtiges Element ist für diese Lageregelung, ist baugleich. Das sind dieselben Sternsensor. Er wird nur in einem anderen Modus quasi verwendet.
Jetzt sind die Missionen von Anfang an so geplant worden, dass beide gleichzeitig kommen. Ich meine, die Anforderungen jetzt für Infrarot-Teleskopie, Anforderungen für Radioosmologie, das mag ja aus ganz anderen wissenschaftlichen Erwägungen herauskommen und nimmt von daher auch ganz andere Prozesse im Rahmen des Beschlusses, wollen wir das tun, wollen wir das nicht tun. Das ist ja halt ein ewigen Vorlauf. War man da von Anfang an von diesem Gedanken beseelt, lasst uns doch hier gleich zwei auf einen Streich machen, oder waren das unterschiedliche Entwicklungen, wo man dann irgendwann gesagt hat, naja, also vielleicht kriegen wir beides auch noch ein bisschen billiger, wenn wir sie beide zum gleichen Zeitpunkt starten?
Nein, das war der treibende Faktor tatsächlich. Also das ist so, dass die ESA halt Projekte auswählt, die gemacht werden sollen in der Zukunft. Und das ist ein ständiger Prozess, dass ständig neue Programme auch aus der Zukunft gemacht werden. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat man gesagt, das sind zwei wichtige Sachen, die Europa machen will. Diese beiden Aufgaben, die müssen wir erledigen. Aber das muss irgendwie so gemacht werden, dass die Kosten reduziert werden, weil das Geld nicht unendlich ist. Und das war ein treibender Faktor, dass man tatsächlich diese beiden Satelliten zusammengebaut hat.
Aber man könnte ja auch erwarten, dass dann, ich meine, dadurch steigt ja auch die Komplexität des Projektes, weil natürlich zwei unterschiedlich arbeitende Gruppen, also man hat sowieso viele unterschiedliche arbeitende Gruppen, auch beim einzelnen Projekt. Aber bei so einem Doppelprojekt wird es halt gleich nochmal mehr, die ganz unterschiedliche Anforderungen haben, zumindest was bestimmte Teilbereiche betrifft. Und von daher natürlich nochmal eigene Verzögerungen und Komplikationen mit einbringen. War das ein zusätzliches Problem, oder ist das dann nicht so?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich kann jetzt nicht für die Leute sprechen, in ESDEC, das Entwicklungszentrum der ESA, die das Projekt also betreiben. Aber es war garantiert eine Herausforderung, die überglänzend gemeistert worden ist. Also ein Projekt alleine hat natürlich schon viele Probleme. Es gibt immer irgendwelche Startverzögerungen, es gibt immer irgendwelche Entwicklungsprobleme, weil wie gesagt, wir machen Prototypen. Wir haben wissenschaftliche Aufgaben zu erfüllen. Das sind Herausforderungen und das ist nicht ein Satellit von der Stange, sondern jeder Satellit wird für diese Aufgabe konzipiert, erstellt. Entwicklung wird vorangetrieben in Europa. Und ein Projekt alleine ist schon kompliziert genug, zwei Projekte unter einen Hut zu kriegen. Es war, wie gesagt, ich kann nicht sprechen für Project, aber so wie sich das mir dargestellt hat, war das schon eine große Herausforderung. Und genauso sehen wir das hier in der ESOC. Es gibt große Vorteile. Zum Beispiel betreiben wir beide Satelliten mit, wie soll ich das sagen, anderthalb Teams. Wir haben also ein Team für Herschel, ein Team für Planck. Aber manche Leute, zum Beispiel die Techniker, die Spacecraft-Kontrolle, betreuen beide Satelliten.
Weil die Technik einfach eh identisch ist.
Weil die Aufgabe identisch ist, die Daten runterzuspären, wenn der Satellit vorbeikommt und so weiter und so fort.
Und das spart Kosten.
Und das spart Kosten ist aber teilweise auch ein zusätzlicher Aufwand. Weil zwei Teams sich koordinieren müssen. Na gut, ich meine, man muss das Herausforderung sehen. Wir machen das nicht aus Spaß, sondern wir machen das, um halt quasi zu dem Ziel zu gelangen. Und das hat bei Herschel und Planck also wunderbar funktioniert. Ich spreche jetzt, wie gesagt, aus der Sicht des operationellen Betriebs. Wir sind die ganze Geschichte so angegangen. Auch aus Gründen der Kostenreduktion ist man davon weggegangen, jetzt ein Netz von Bodenstationen zu betreiben, sodass man den Satellit 24 Stunden um die Uhr beobachten kann. Also die Daten übertragen. Das heißt also, die Kommandos in Echtzeit hochschicken und die Telemetrie in Echtzeit einsammeln. Um Kosten zu sparen, hat man das auch so gemacht, dass der Satellit hochautonom ist und quasi seine Messungen selber betreibt und alles aufnimmt auf dem Recorder. Wir haben es eben schon angesprochen, einmal alle 24 Stunden, weil der Satellit ist quasi vereinfacht, aber jetzt auf diesem fixen Punkt von der Erde, von der Sonne abgewandt. Die Erde dreht sich 24 Stunden, und dann wird es wieder Tag und Nacht, einmal um sich selber. Das heißt also, kann man grob wie immer darum sagen, alle 24 Stunden kommt der Satellit an der Bodenstation vorbei, bzw. die Bodenstation mit der Erde dreht sich so, dass der Satellit wieder Kontakt haben kann. Dann kommt es jetzt so, dass der Satellit also quasi seine Messung, die er die letzten 24 Stunden auf einen Rekorder aufgenommen hat, innerhalb von drei Stunden zu dieser Bodenstationsspiel. Das ist also quasi der Prozess, in dem wir die wissenschaftlichen Daten einsammeln. Während der Zeit, während wir also Kontakt haben, sammeln wir nicht nur die Telemetriedaten ein, sondern wir sagen dem Satelliten auch, was er die nächsten 24 Stunden, und auf der sicheren Seite zu sein, was er die nächsten 48 Stunden tun soll. Das heißt, wir rechnen damit, dass wir immer einmal am Tag Kontakt haben. Aber wenn es ein Problem gibt, zum Beispiel in einer Bodenstation, dass die Bodenstation nicht verfügbar ist, dann ist der Satellit trotzdem fähig, noch die nächsten 24 Stunden zu überleben.
Welche Bodenstation kommt denn normalerweise zum Einsatz? Ist es in der Regel immer dieselbe?
Das ist in der Regel dieselbe, aber wir brauchen Flexibilität, weil wir uns die Bodenstation teilen mit anderen Satelliten. Wir haben also nicht eine Bodenstation, die uns selber gehört. Das wird auch keinen Sinn machen, eine Bodenstation zu bauen, die man nur drei Stunden am Tag nutzt, sondern wir teilen das mit anderen Missionen.
Aber man bedient sich schon des S-Trek-Bodenstationsnetzwerks.
Richtig, ja, genau. Und auch eine clevere Geschichte, muss man sie wieder vorstellen. Ich komme immer wieder darauf zurück. Sonne, Erde, Satellit, alles in einer Reihe. Die Sonne ist auf der einen Seite, das heißt, wenn wir Tag haben, dann ist der Satellit auf der anderen Seite, dann ist er nachts. Also nehmen wir natürlich eine Bodenstation, bei der es Nacht ist, wenn wir Tag haben. Das heißt, wir haben unsere Prime Crown Station, unsere Hauptbodenstation, die wir benutzen, ist in Nord-Australien. Aber wir teilen uns das gesamte S-Trek-Netzwerk auch mit den anderen Satelliten. Manchmal muss man natürlich auch ausweichen, das verschiebt sich nach hinten und nach vorne. Eine andere Bodenstation, die wir benutzen können, ist Cepreros bei Madrid in Spanien. Und dann haben wir auch noch vorgesehen für den Betrieb für Herschel und Planck, falls es mal zu Notfällen kommt, die Bodenstation in Kuro. Dabei muss man sagen, du hast Estrek erwähnt. Estrek ist ein Netzwerk von Satellitenschüsseln, die wir rund um die Erde betreiben. Und besteht aus hauptsächlich 15 Meter Antennen. Und was wir in der letzten Zeit aufgebaut haben, ist auch ein Netz von 35 Meter großen Antennen. Also die Größe der Antenne, das ist ein physikalisches Gesetz, hat auch damit zu tun, wie gut man ein Signal, ein schwaches Signal aus dem Weltraum auffangen kann.
Und die Kommunikation läuft dann über das X-Band. Also Estrek war ja tatsächlich hier das Thema der letzten Sendung, die 28. Ausgabe, von da habe ich das auch noch frische Erinnerungen, wo dann eben auch zur Sprache kam, dass eben manche Bodenstationen explizit für diese Deep Space Missionen ausgerüstet sind, die dann jetzt hier im Wesentlichen zum Einsatz kommen dürften.
Ja, das ist richtig. Und deswegen sage ich also quasi, dass wir die Hauptbodenstation Nonorsia haben, Zebrero als Backup, falls wir ausweichen müssen, und nur für Notfälle eine 15-Meter-Schlüssel, weil Kuru ist also eine kleinere Antenne, weil wir also die hohen Bitraten, die wir brauchen, um die Informationen, die sich auf dem Satelliten angesammelt haben, die wir aufgenommen haben, die müssen ja in einer verkürzten Zeit runtergespielt werden, was man in 24 Stunden aufnimmt, muss man in drei Stunden runterspielen, deswegen brauchen wir eine große Bitrate. Und das kann man mit dem Link-Budget, also mit dem Signal, das von einem Satelliten gesendet wird, kann man das nicht machen. Man kann also nicht zu 1,5 Megabit pro Sekunde gehen, das ist unsere Datenrate, mit der wir die Daten runterspielen, wenn wir eine 15-Meter-Schüssel benutzen. Das heißt also, die 15-Meter-Schüssel ist also quasi eine Schüssel, die wir dann benutzen würden, Antenne, ich sage jetzt einfach Schüssel, die wir dann benutzen würden, wenn wir zum Beispiel den Satelliten retten müssten aus einer Anomalie, wenn der Satellit also in so einen sogenannten Überlebensmodus in Survival-Mode gegangen wäre, dann kann man zu geringeren Bitraten gehen, die nicht dafür gedacht sind, wissenschaftliche Daten runterzuspielen, sondern einfach nur den Status des Satelliten zu übertragen, dass wir den dann wieder quasi auf die Reihe kriegen.
Also Herrschel, das Infrarot-Weltraumteleskop ist gemeinsam mit Planck geplant worden. Man teilt sich bestimmte Ressourcen, man teilt sich eine bestimmte Technik. Davon abgesehen sind das jetzt erstmal separate Missionen und dein Einsatzgebiet ist ja jetzt im Wesentlichen auch nur Herrschel. Und durch diesen speziellen L2-Punkt hat man eben diesen Komfort, dass man in so einem 24-Stunden-Zyklus da die Kommunikation aufnimmt. Das ist ja auch, glaube ich, so viel generell für die Arbeit, dann auch eigentlich eine relativ entspannte Eigenschaft, oder?
Also ich meine, wir wären dumm gewesen, wenn wir gesagt hätten, wir nehmen eine Bodenstation, dass wir dann immer nachts reinkommen müssen.
Ja gut, aber wenn man jetzt auf Cerebros oder sowas ausweicht, dann bedeutet das ja im Prinzip, ne?
Das ist richtig, ja, das ist richtig. Wobei wir hier auch unterscheiden müssen. Also der Betrieb des Satelliten wird in dem Team quasi ausgeführt von dem Spacecraft-Controller. Das sind also Techniker, das sind wirklich auch Schichtarbeiter, die für andere Missionen auch tatsächlich Schichten rund um die Uhr arbeiten. Und jetzt kommen wir wieder darauf zurück. Also der Vorteil, gemeinsame Missionen zu machen, war auch der, dass wir zweimal drei Stunden wunderbar in eine Spacecraft-Controller-Schicht reinpacken können. Und dann machen wir das natürlich so, dass unsere Anforderungen an das S-Track-Netzwerk sind. Also jede Mission muss sagen, was will es denn? Dann muss das alles verteilt werden. Also die Zeit, die eine Bohrenschätzung zur Verfügung ist, ist also quasi die Ressource und die müssen wir uns teilen. Und unsere Anforderungen sind da, okay, wir wollen so haben, dass also Herschel und Planck immer nacheinander kommen, die drei Stunden, mit einer kurzen Pause zwischendurch, dass wir das alles in eine Schicht reinpacken können, für einen Spacecraft-Controller. Das ist also derjenige, der den rechten Kontakt mit dem Satelliten hat und die Daten runterspielt und die neuen Kommandos hochschickt. Und der wird natürlich unterstützt auch von dem Team, das im Hintergrund arbeitet. Das sind dann die Ingenieuren und die Data-Analysts, die sich also dann quasi normale Büroarbeitszeiten haben. Und selbst wenn wir CEPEROS benutzen für eine gewisse Zeit oder eine gewisse Periode, weil ein anderer Satellit oder ein Start von anderen Missionen geplant ist und nur noch nicht zur Verfügung steht, dann ist es manchmal so, dass der Satellit nachts kommt. Wir kommen nicht alle nachts rein, das Bacon ist nachts da. Wir kommen am nächsten Morgen rein und gucken uns dann die Daten an, ob alles in Ordnung ist, ob alles so gelaufen ist. Falls etwas schiefgehen sollte, dann ist natürlich alles so geplant und vorbereitet und alles so ausgerichtet, dass dann der Spacecraft-Controller die Sache erst mal versucht, selber auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Aber er wird unterstützt von einem sogenannten On-Call-Ingenieur. Das heißt, es ist also tatsächlich jemand, wegen medizinischer Notdienste oder so, der ein Telefon hat und immer erreichbar ist. Das heißt, notfalls kann dann auch der Ingenieur oder auch der Spacecraft-Operation-Manager dann nachts reinkommen, falls das so vorderlich ist.
Falls der Satellit Husten hat? Hat er denn schon mal Husten gehabt?
Ja, es kommen Sachen vor, die wir wieder auf die Reihe bringen müssen. Da gibt es verschiedene Sachen. Es gibt tatsächlich unvorhergesehene Computer-Abstürze, würde ich es mal so nennen. Die einfach, ganz banal, gibt immer irgendwelche Sachen, bevor ich drum rum ist, gibt es immer irgendwelche Sachen, die kaputt gehen können. Es gibt auch Sachen, die nicht so arbeiten, wie sie vorhergesehen waren. Das heißt, immer so ein Lernprofil. Am Anfang gibt es auch erst mal eine Commissioning von Satelliten, wo man alles durchmisst, alles durchtestet und dann sagt, was müssen wir machen, was müssen wir machen, und auf die Reihe kriegen. Das kann also jederzeit passieren. Was auch passieren kann, ist, man befindet sich im Weltraum auch in einer Umgebung, die von der Strahlung her gesehen nicht so freundlich ist. Es gibt die kosmische Strahlung. Dann gibt es die Sonnenstrahlung, die uns quasi der kosmischen Strahlung schützt. Die Sonne ist quasi ein Schutzschild, in dem die Erde sich auch befindet. Die Erde selber hat auch ein Magnetfeld und schützt sich also wieder von der Sonnenstrahlung. Da kann es auch passieren, dass ein Computer abstürzt, weil das Computerprogramm gestört wird. Wir nennen das Single Event Upset. Es gibt einen hochenergischen Schüttchen. Single Event Upset. Man kann sich das so vorstellen, dass ein Teilchen auf den Computership einschlägt. Und aus den ganzen 1 und Nullen, ein Computerprogramm ist ja nichts anderes als 1 und Nullen, aus einer 1 auf einmal eine 0 macht oder aus einer 0 eine 1 macht. Dann weiß das Programm nicht mehr, was es tun soll.
Aber so ein bisschen fehlertolerant dürfte die Hardware ja sein. Wenn er die 0 auf die 1 umschlägt, dann merkt er zumindest, dass das passiert ist.
Das ist richtig. Das ist auch Teil des Konzepts, Teil der Entwicklung eines Satelliten. Man kann Bauteile natürlich vor Strahlung schützen. Passiv macht man das natürlich nicht so gern. Oder man kann das nicht irgendwie im Bleimantel packen. Gewicht ist teuer, Gewicht spielt eine Rolle. Aber es gibt natürlich auch Computerprogramme oder einfach Prozesse, mit denen man die Software testen kann und das also quasi softwaremäßig absichern kann. Man nennt das EDAC oder Scrubbing. Das heißt, es gibt kleine Routinen, die im Hintergrund laufen und quasi den Inhalt eines Programmes oder den Inhalt einer Adresse ablesen und das dann durch einen Algorithmus schicken, der dann ein Ergebnis hat, eine sogenannte Checksum. Und die Checksum ist auch abgelegt für diese Memory-Adresse. Und wenn es da einen Unterschied gibt, dann kann dieses EDAC sagen, hier ist etwas kaputt.
Also, er beprüft sich sozusagen die ganze Zeit auf Integrität.
Genau. Und das ist für einige Komponenten sehr gut gemacht worden, für andere weniger gut. Das heißt also, bei Herschel ist es tatsächlich so, dass wir tatsächlich einige Komponenten haben, wo das, es sind auch Studien gemacht worden, wo das irgendwie, würde ich mal so sagen, das kostet mir sehr wahrscheinlich einen Kopf jetzt, wo das nicht so ernst genommen worden ist. Und wir kriegen das halt hier mehr oder weniger knallhart ab. Es ist tatsächlich so, das kann auch nachträglich nicht implementiert werden. Dass einige Komponenten nicht so fehlertolerant sind. Und das ist auch eine sehr interessante Geschichte, die wir jetzt gerade lernen. Die Wettervorhersage im Weltall, wir nennen das auch Wettervorhersage für die Strahlung. Und dann gibt es auch verschiedene Dienste, Wettervorhersagen, die wir auch reagieren, die wir bauen. Die aber hauptsächlich tatsächlich darauf abgestimmt sind, wie ist denn, dass die Strahlenverhältnisse im erdnahen Bereich und für Erdumlauf bahnen. Und auf L2 verhält sich das ganz anders. Also es ist so, wenn zum Beispiel also auf den einschlägigen Webseiten dann angekündigt wird, dass jetzt große Sonnenaktivität stattfindet. Wir befinden uns gerade, also die Sonne hat ein Zyklus von großer Aktivität zu weniger großen Aktivität in einer Periode von elf Jahren. Und wir befinden uns gerade auf einem einsteigenden Ast, aufsteigenden Ast. Das heißt also, die Sonnenaktivität nimmt zu. Und dann gibt es halt Warnungen. Und dann ist es tatsächlich so, dass wenn wir höhere Sonnenaktivitäten haben, dass auch quasi die Sonnenaktivität im Erdmagnetfeld quasi zu Strahlenveränderungen führt oder auch die Sonnenstrahlung selber die erdnahen Umlaufbahnen erreicht. Und die Satelliten dann tatsächlich mehr von diesem Single-Event-Upset sehen oder wir bereiten auch die Satelliten davor und sagen, jetzt schalten wir die Instrumente ab. Bei Herschel ist es genau umgekehrt. Also es sieht tatsächlich so aus, wenn man einen solchen Satelliten, das ist alles noch nicht ausgegoren, ausgereift ist es tatsächlich, was wir gerade jetzt lernen. Wir sind im Lernprozess. Bei uns sieht es tatsächlich so aus, wenn also die Warnungen kommen, dann heißt das für uns, oh, jetzt sieht es eigentlich besser aus, jetzt wird es bei uns ruhiger. Es sieht tatsächlich so aus, dass die Sonne mehr oder weniger ein Schutzschild aufbaut und uns vor der kosmischen Strahlung schützt.
Und wenn die Entwarnung kommt, dann fangen alle an zu zittern.
Es kristallisiert sich, wie gesagt, das ist eine schöne wissenschaftliche Studie für sich selber. Und da hat man wenig Erfahrung, weil halt auch bisher noch wenig gemacht worden ist in L2.
Das Projekt ist ja auch noch relativ neu, also der Start war 2009, also es ist gerade mal zwei Jahre im All. Wie lange soll Herschel laufen?
Die Lebensdauer ist begrenzt durch das Kühlmittel. Wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass Herschel also sehr kalt sein muss. Das kann man einmal damit erreichen, dass man das passiv macht, wie ich schon gesagt habe, dass man einfach das gegen die Sonnenstrahlung oder Erdstrahlung schützt. Das reicht aber noch nicht. Also man möchte noch zu viel niedrigeren Temperaturen kommen. Und dafür braucht man ein aktives Kühlsystem, das wird betrieben durch eine Kühlflüssigkeit, das ist superfluid Helium, flüssiges Helium, das am Dampfdruckpunkt betrieben wird. Also das ist quasi ein System.
Was heißt das am Dampfdruckpunkt?
Das ist, muss man sich so vorstellen, dass durch die Phasenumwandlung von flüssig zu gasförmig kälterzeugt wird, also Energie vernichtet wird. Man kann gewisse Stoffe am Dampfdruckpunkt so betreiben, dass kontrolliert quasi die Phase von flüssig nach gasförmig übergeht und dadurch entsteht eine Deltatemperatur, dadurch wird gekühlt. Dieses superfluid Helium hat diese Eigenschaft, dass man das machen kann so, dass die Temperatur an diesem Phasenübergang, muss man sich wirklich wie eine Membrane vorstellen, das ist ein flüssiger Tank, eine Membrane und oben ist es noch gasförmig. Das Gas muss natürlich dann abgeleitet werden, es muss ausgasen, damit der Dampf, also mit das stabiles Verhältnis ist, ein Gleichgewicht wieder ist. Dass da Temperaturen herrschen von 1,7 Kelvin, 1,64 Kelvin sind wir momentan. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. 1,6 Kelvin.
Das ist sozusagen nahezu der vollständige Totpunkt.
Das ist, ja, es geht noch, es geht noch kälter.
Es geht noch bis Null Kelvin, ja.
Nee, bis Null geht es nicht. Ich weiß nicht, das existiert gar nicht. Dieses flüssige Helium muss also ständig verdampfen und bestimmt dadurch die Lebenszeit von Herschel. Bei anderen Missionen ist es üblicherweise so, dass die konzipiert sind für einen Lebensdauer von 4 oder 5 Jahren. Und die Faktoren, die das Leben begrenzen, sind entweder Solarpaneele oder meistens ist es der Treibstoff für die Düsen. Bei Herschel ist es so, dass das Helium ungefähr für dreieinhalb Jahre reichen wird seit dem Start. Das heißt, wir rechnen momentan damit, dass wir Herschel noch betreiben können bis Februar 2013.
Und warum nicht länger?
Weil dann sämtliches flüssige Helium, das wir getankt haben, mit dem wir gestartet sind, verdampft ist und nichts mehr verfügbar ist.
Aber warum hat man nicht mehr getankt? Ich weiß, es ist schwer und man muss ja auch reinpassen und so weiter. Man muss ja immer so seine Kompromisse machen. Aber ich meine, wie kommt man auf den Kompromiss? Warum 3,5 Jahre? Warum nicht 5? Hat man gedacht, reicht schon? Oder nach 3,5 Jahren haben wir uns eh alles angeguckt, da kommen keine neuen Erkenntnisse?
Nein, wie du selber sagst, es ist ein Kompromiss. Irgendwo muss man aufhören. Es ist halt dieser Kompromiss. Es wird voraus berechnet, wie viel Masse brauchen wir, um so und so viel Zeit zu betreiben. Dann kommt man auf diesen Kompromiss. Was die Eigenheiten, die Eigenschaften sind, tatsächlich so ein System zu betreiben, und was da die limitierenden Faktoren sind, das weiß ich im Allgemeinen nicht. Ich weiß, dass es ein Riesenaufwand ist, allein schon während des Bauers. Teile des Satelliten. Während der Satellit hier am Boden quasi zusammengeschraubt wird, waren schon 1,5 bis 2 Jahre vor dem Start. Auf dieser Temperatur von 1,7 Kelvin. Und haben seitdem auch nie wieder höhere Temperaturen gesehen.
Das heißt, sie sind gebaut worden und dann kamen sie in eine Kältekammer?
Das System wurde betrieben. Nicht selber in eine Kältekammer, sondern das System selber. Der Kühlschrank lief schon sozusagen. Den Prozess hat sie in Gang gesetzt. Solange man auf dem Boden ist, kann man natürlich noch nachtanken, was auch nicht endlos geht. Aber wenn dann irgendwann tatsächlich mal die Strippe gezogen ist und der Satellit im Weltraum schwebt, dann kann man natürlich nicht mehr so einfach nachtanken.
Ja, das bringt mich auf einen anderen Punkt. Nämlich, also teilweise haben wir es ja schon angesprochen, aber ich denke, das ist jetzt auch noch mal sehr interessant, weil wir jetzt auch bei vielen Betrachtungen hier in anderen Folgen, da sind ja so einige Aspekte schon aufgekommen. Wir haben über Operations gesprochen, wir haben über Missionsplanungen gesprochen. Infrarot-Teleskopie kam hier in der Sendung zu Sophia auch schon zur Erwähnung, aber relativ wenig über dieses, was ist eigentlich jetzt wirklich drin in so einem Satelliten. Du hast ja jetzt im Prinzip auch die ganze Planungs- und Bauphase auch aktiv mit begleitet. Was muss man denn einfach reinbauen? Ich meine, dass das Ding irgendwie einen Spiegel hat, ist klar, es ist irgendwie ein Teleskop, wir haben das Schild, wir haben diese Kühlvorrichtung und es muss natürlich auch eine Kommunikationseinrichtung geben. War es das jetzt schon? Was ist drin in dem Satelliten und wie hat sich das so entwickelt über diese Planungszeit?
Das Konzept eines Satelliten, was muss der Satellit können, was für Komponenten muss der Satellit haben, steht und fällt mit der Aufgabe, die er hat. Also verschiedene Satelliten werden verschieden gebaut sein. Aber es gibt natürlich, wir teilen, es gibt Standard-Komponenten, was Standard heißt nicht, dass man die von der Stange kaufen kann.
Aber das sind Sachen, die man eigentlich fast immer braucht.
Es sind quasi, wir unterteilen das in sogenannte Sub-Systeme, Untersysteme, die man dann quasi baukastenförmig zusammenstellt, aber die typischerweise jeder Satellit hat, egal in welcher Art und Weise man die betreibt. Man kann also grob sagen, dass man den Satelliten in zwei Teile teilen kann. Einmal ist es das die sogenannte Payload, niemand zahlt da irgendwas, es geht einfach darum, das sind die Nutzer des Satelliten. Zum Beispiel wissenschaftliche Instrumente, wie wir sie auch in Herschel haben, drei Stück. Oder die Instrumente, die wir auf Planck haben. Zu dieser Nutzlast gehören nicht nur die Instrumente selber, sondern vielleicht auch spezifische Komponenten, die ganz speziell für diese Mission, für diesen Satelliten, gebraucht werden, wie zum Beispiel dieses Kühlsystem von Herschel, um die Temperatur zu erreichen. Das ist für uns alles Nutzlast. Das ist etwas, was sehr spezifisch ist und was letztendlich die Aufgabe des Satelliten bestimmt. Die zweite Komponente, die zweite große Gruppe ist dann halt dieses Service-Modul, wie nennt man das? Oder man kann es auch Bus nennen, der diese Standardaufgaben erledigt.
Warum nennst du das Bus?
Das ist so Sprachgebrauch. Man kann sich das vorstellen, wie ein Dienst, den man anbietet. Wir sind die Busfahrer. Ein Bus hat Räder, ein Bus hat Lenkrad und hat Sitze.
Das ist das, was die Payload da hinfährt.
Das ist das, was die Payload da hinfährt und unterstützt mit allem, was sie brauchen. Also mit Elektrizität, mit Datenaustausch und so weiter und so fort. Wenn man da jetzt in Einzelheiten gehen will, kann man jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, dass dieses Service-Modul dieser Bus verschiedene standardmäßige Aufgaben erledigen muss, wie zum Beispiel die Lage-Regelung. Ganz wichtig, es gibt Satelliten, die vielleicht einfach nur keine großen Anforderungen haben an die Lage-Regelung. Bei einem Weltraumteleskop wie Herschel, wo man tatsächlich also weit entfernte Galaxien gucken möchte, ist die Lage-Regelung sehr, sehr wichtig, weil man eine gewisse Stabilität haben will.
Also man braucht, wichtig im Sinne von, man braucht eine extreme Präzision.
Genau.
Es reicht nicht, wenn man so Pi mal Daumen sagt, naja, Orbit ist in etwa erreicht. Wir gucken grundsätzlich in die richtige Himmelsrichtung. Da will man sich verdammt sicher sein, dass man in die richtige Richtung guckt.
Richtig. Wir müssen sehr präzise sein.
Wie kann man diese Präzision irgendwie greifbar machen? Wie präzise das jetzt sein muss, auch im Verhältnis vielleicht zu anderen Sachen?
Ich habe das mal spaß und zauber ausgerechnet. Wir haben jetzt besser als Spezifikation, dadurch, dass wir auch die Sachen verbessern und auch Fine-Tuning machen und so weiter. Da haben wir jetzt mit Herschel eine Lage-Regelung, eine Genauigkeit von einer Bogensekunde erreicht. Eine Bogensekunde, das ist ein Grad, hat 60 Bogenminuten. Und eine Bogeminute hat 60 Bogensekunden. Greifbar machen, wenn man…
Klingt jetzt erstmal nicht besonders präzise so. Sekunde.
Doch, das ist sehr präzise. 360 Grad, ein Grad ist aufgeteilt in 60 Bogenminuten, aufgeteilt in 60 Bogensekunden.
Also ein Dreitausendsechshundertstel des gesamten Grads.
Wenn man einfach mal eine Dartscheibe nehmen würde in so einem Papp, dann ist das Bull-Auge in der Mitte. Das ist 1,27 Zentimeter groß. Und das muss man treffen aus 5 Metern Entfernung. Herschel wäre in der Lage, dieses Ziel zu treffen, wenn es 2.600 Meter entfernt wäre von dieser Dartscheibe. So muss man sich die Genauigkeit vorstellen. Also der Sled steht irgendwo da hinten am Bahnhof. Und hier steht die Scheibe. Und der könnte so genau in diese Richtung gucken.
2.600 Meter zielt er auf eine Fläche von?
1,27 trifft er einen Punkt, der 1,27 Zentimeter groß ist.
Das ist schon ziemlich genau.
Das ist präzise. Und ist auch nicht so einfach zu erreichen. Es braucht also nicht nur Spezifikationen. Und die Komponenten des Lagerregelungssystems werden aus Spezifikationen gebaut. Sondern es braucht tatsächlich Verfeinerungen im Orbit.
Aber was schaut sich die Lagerregelung an? Schaut sich die Sterne an?
Es gibt verschiedene Komponenten von der Lagerregelung wieder. Also Lagerregelung ist bestimmt durch Aktuatoren. Das heißt einfach Geräte, mit denen man die Lage ändern kann. Das ist auch, wie soll man sich das vorstellen? Auf dem Boden ist das einfach. Wenn man also was wie ich da einen Fernrohr hat und möchte das in eine andere Richtung gucken, dann nimmt man die Hand und dreht das da hin. Und das steht auf dem Stativ. Im Weltraum ist es, als ob man im Schwimmbad ist. Man kann sich nirgendwo abstutzen. Das heißt, man braucht also Aktuatoren. Das sind hauptsächlich, man benutzt Düsen. Damit erzeugt man dann ein externes Moment. Da kann man sich also wirklich irgendwie abstützen, als ob man sich von außen abstützen lässt. Man schmeißt also Masse nach hinten. Wir haben eben schon darüber gesprochen, man lässt etwas hinter sich. Typischerweise für andere Missionen ist das auch etwas, was die Lebenszeit begrenzt, weil man tatsächlich Masse hinter sich schmeißt. Aber anders kann man es nicht machen, weil man sich halt irgendwo abstützen muss. Das ist aber, weil man sich nicht abstützen kann. Zum Beispiel, man ist auf dem Boot auf dem See und hat die Rute verloren und möchte wieder ans Ufer kommen. Man hat zufällig Steine im Boot. Das ist ein blödes Beispiel, wer hat zufällig Steine im Boot. Aber die einzige Möglichkeit, zum anderen Ufer zu kommen, ist halt, die Steine zu nehmen und in eine Richtung zu schmeißen. Das Boot wird sich in die andere Richtung bewegen. Aber wenn man irgendwann keine Steine mehr hat, kann man sich nicht mehr... Da hat man wirklich nichts mehr, um sich anzustützen. Aber Diesel-Lagerregelung mit den Düsen ist nie so genau. Das wird tatsächlich als einen Vorschlag, kann man nehmen, sage ich jetzt mal im übertriebenen Sinne. Das heißt, man braucht also gerade für solche Sachen wie Weltraumteleskop einen feineren Aktuator, ein feineres Stellklid. Und das sind üblicherweise Trallräder. Das sind einfach Massen, die sich mit einer geschwimmten Geschwindigkeit drehen. Nicht nur...
Schwungräder.
Kreisel ist ein bisschen irreführend, weil Kreisel haben wir auch, aber als Sensoren... Also der Unterschied zwischen Kreiseln und zwischen diesen Reaktionsrädern ist, dass die einfach eine große Masse haben, relativ große Masse. Die dimensioniert das für diese Satelliten. Und das ist ein geschlossenes System. Das heißt, also die Drehrate von dem Satelliten und die Drehrate von diesem Trallrad wird immer gleich bleiben. Wenn man jetzt mehr Strom durch dieses Trallrad schickt, dann wird das Trallrad sich schneller drehen. Da der Satellit aber von nichts festgehalten wird, das haben wir genau den umgekehrten Fall von ihm, man kann sich nicht abstützen, das Satellit wird nicht festgehalten, dreht sich das in die andere Richtung. Das heißt also, man betreibt dieses Trallrad und man sagt dem Satelliten, ich möchte mich jetzt in die andere Richtung drehen. Das Trallrad wird dann simplerweise vereinfacht in die andere Richtung beschleunigt und dadurch dreht der Satellit sich in die Richtung, die man will. Und dann stoppt man das Trallrad wieder, indem man in die andere Richtung dreht und dann bleibt das Teleskop da stehen.
Die Aktuatoren kann man natürlich auch als Einsatz bringen, wenn man weiß, wo man hin will. Das heißt, man muss ja erst mal gucken, wo bin ich, damit man bestimmen kann, wo man hin will.
Genau. Das heißt, jetzt kommen wir also auf die Sensorenseite. Was üblicherweise benutzt wird, sind Sensoren, die die relative Lage bestimmen können. Das sind sogenannte Kreisel. Da haben wir die Kreisel wieder. Deswegen wollte ich nicht, dass wir das vermischen mit Trialrädern. Die Kreisel haben also genau den umgekehrten Effekt für diese Trialräder. Das kann man sich vorstellen, wenn man als Handwerker schon mal eine Flex in der Hand gehabt hat oder eine Baumaschine oder eine Flex. Eine Flex dreht sich mit einer hohen Geschwindigkeit. Wenn man diese Flex versucht, irgendwie zu drehen, dann verhält sich dieses Werkzeug irgendwie merkwürdig. Das geht erst mal in die Richtung, wie man will.
Oder wenn man einfach so ein Vorderrad vom Fahrrad ausbaut und drehen lässt und festhält.
Genau, das ist ein schönes Beispiel aus dem Physikunterricht in der Schule. Das heißt, wenn der Satellit sich dreht, die Lage beeinflusst wird durch die Düsen oder durch einen externen Störmoment oder sowas, und sich in eine Richtung bewegt, dann merken das solche Kreise, die sich mit hoher Geschwindigkeit drehen.
Weil einfach so Kräfte an der Narbe entstehen, die man einfach messen kann.
Und die misst man. Und das ist sehr genau. Der Nachteil von diesen Sensoren ist, dass man keinen absoluten Haltepunkt hat. Man hat kein Wissen über seine absolute Position. Sondern man kann nur sagen, hier bin ich jetzt mit dem Satelliten. Keine Ahnung, wo ich bin. Ich kann genau sagen, dass ich mich jetzt in den letzten zwei Sekunden in die Richtung bewegt habe. Um jetzt festzustellen, wo ich mich mit absoluter Genauigkeit befinde, also mit dem absoluten Wissen, gucke ich jetzt nach Norden oder gucke ich nach Süden. Im Gegensatz zu relativ, ich bewege mich gerade mit einer Geschwindigkeit von zwei Bogenminuten, nimmt man üblicherweise Sternensensoren. Das sind also tatsächlich einfach nur CCT-Kameras, die Sternbilder aufnehmen. Richtig Sternenkonstellation. Die abgleichen, die modernen Sternensensoren. Das ist auch wieder ein schönes Beispiel, wie die Technologie vorangeschritten ist mit Iso und mit Herschel. Bei Iso war es noch nicht der Fall, dass man jetzt quasi ein Bild aufnehmen kann von einer Konstellation von Sternen und dadurch die absolute Lage im Weltraum bestimmen kann. So, wie wir das hier auch von der Erde aus machen. Wenn wir sich ein Sternbild angucken, dann kann man sagen, das ist die Richtung. Also relativ zum Sonnensystem.
Das war bei Iso noch nicht so.
Das war bei Iso nicht so. Bei Iso hat man auch Sternensensoren benutzt. Aber da hat man das so gemacht, dass man also, einfach weil die Sternensensoren noch nicht, die Programme noch nicht so weit entwickelt waren und auch die Prozessorgeschwindigkeit oder die Fähigkeit des Sternensensorns nicht so weit ausgereicht ist. Da hat man das so gemacht bei Iso, dass man sich nur einen Stern festgehalten hat. Man hat also diesen CCD-Ship benutzt und wusste schon im Voraus, in welcher Lage der Satellit ist.
Das war ein Teil des Programms.
Nein, nein, das ist Teil des Programms. Man muss einmal seine Lage feststellen, indem man einen besonderen Modus hat, der nicht sehr genau in der Lage-Regelung ist. Die kann man nicht benutzen, um eine wissenschaftliche Messung zu machen. Man macht ein Mapping und hat also genau dasselbe, dass man eine Konstellation von Sternen hat. Das kann der Sternensensor an Bord aber selber nicht ausrechnen, sondern das wurde zum Boden gefunkt bei ESO. Dann haben sich unsere Kollegen von Flight Dynamics hingesetzt, haben die Sternen-Konstellation genommen, haben gesagt, der Satellit schaut jetzt in die Richtung. Dann haben wir ihn einen Kommando hochgeschickt und haben den Satelliten gesagt, du schaust jetzt in die Richtung. Ab heute weißt du, ab diesem Zeitpunkt schaust du in die Richtung. Von diesem Punkt an hat man den Sternensensor anders betrieben. Indem man dem Sternensensor gesagt hat, wenn du dich jetzt ein anderes Objekt angucken willst, musst du dich ungefähr in die Richtung bewegen für fünf Bogenminuten. Und da wirst du einen Stern finden. Und diesen Stern, den konnte man quasi mit dem Sternensensor festhalten. Das Programm, das die Lageregelung kontrolliert hat, hat also immer gesagt, der Stern, der ist ja eine Punkt auf dem CCD-Ship, der muss sich immer da befinden, auf diesem einen Pixel, also X-Y-Koordinat. Und wenn er wegdriftet, dann müssen wir den wieder zurückbringen.
Und dann entsprechend das Tracking mit den aktuellen Toren.
Und dann hat man genau einen Kommando zu den Reaktionsrädern geschickt, die Reaktionsräder haben sich da zurückgedreht. Und man hat also erreicht, dass das Teleskop immer in diese Einrichtung geguckt hat, dass der Stern genau ein Pixel, oder die Position durch die Pixel angegeben hat, quasi trifft.
Wie aufgelöst sind denn diese CCDs? Man ist ja heute so einiges gewohnt. Was ist da so erforderlich, um sich da zu orientieren?
Die Genauigkeit des CCD-Schips ist nicht die Genauigkeit, die man erreichen kann, indem man halt clevere Algorithmen hat und clevere Sachen macht. Wie gesagt, das ist auch wieder ein Fortschritt. Man macht das alles jetzt sehr detailliert, aber man macht folgenden Trick. Wenn man also einen Stern abbilden will auf dem CCD-Ship, wie man auf einer ganz normalen CCD-Karte möchte, dann möchte man kein scharfes Bild haben. Ein Gegenteil. Also der Stern wäre ein Punkt. Man möchte ein unscharfes Bild haben. Das heißt, das Sternbild wird defokussiert. Und dadurch erreicht man, dass das Signal, dass der Stern, ein Stern, von vielen noch ein CCD-Ship, auf dem CCD-Ship hinterlässt, sich über mehrere Pixel von diesem Charge-Couple-Device, die bestehend aus einzelnen Pixeln des Sterns, über mehrere Pixel verteilt. Und dann wendet man Algorithmus an, der also die Verteilung des Signals eines Sterns nimmt und genau weiß, aha, ein Pixel von dem CCD-Stern ist völlig beschienen. Und alle Pixels, die also quasi in der Nachbarschaft liegen, der eine ist zu 30 Prozent, der andere ist zu 5 Prozent und so weiter.
Und dann kann man das halt entsprechend hochrechnen und weiß, man liegt gar nicht mal nur auf einem Pixel, sondern man liegt genauso zu 30 Prozent auf dem Pixel und so 70 Prozent auf dem anderen.
Genau, dadurch, dass man die Signale nimmt von den ganzen Pixels, die auch noch drum herum liegen, kann man genau sagen, das Zentrum von dem Kreis, weil ein defokussiertes Signal vom Stern ist ja genau eine Kreisform, kann man genau sagen, dass der Mittelpunkt von diesem Kreis auf dieser Koordinate liegt, innerhalb dieses Charge-Couples.
Das heißt, damit erhöht man quasi die Auflösung. Aber wie viele Pixel sind es denn jetzt? Also ich meine jetzt rein hardware-technisch, mit wie viel fängt man erst mal an?
Das kann ich nicht vergleichen, die Zahlen habe ich nicht. Also das, wie soll man sagen, das Feld, das Sichtfeld ist, glaube ich, vier mal fünf Burgen Minuten von diesem Sternsensor. Es kommt natürlich darauf an, welche Optik man dahinter macht, ob man das weiter vergrößert oder weiter fokussiert. Aber genaue Zahlen, wie gesagt, kann ich jetzt nicht.
Aber sind diese CCDs, es dürfte sich ja hierbei schon um ein High-End-Produkt handeln. Ist es wichtig, dass man viele Pixel hat oder ist es vor allem wichtig, dass die Dinger jetzt extrem rauscharm sind? Oder sind die das automatisch, weil das alles so enorm gekühlt ist?
Okay, der CCD von dem Sternsensor ist nicht enorm gekühlt. Er ist nicht Teil von diesem cryogenen System. Das ist außerhalb der Lage-Regelung nichts mit der Beobachtung zu tun, die die Instrumente machen. Obwohl der CCD-Strip auch gekühlt ist, aber das ist ganz einfaches, ganz normales mit einem Peltier-Element, also Umgebungstemperatur. Wir starten mit Umgebungstemperatur mit 30 Grad. Dann hat er tatsächlich zu viel Rauschen, also darauf kommt es an. Er wird runtergekühlt auf minus 13 Grad.
Verstehe, aber wenn ich dich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist es bei Herschel so, dass man sich jetzt schon aktiv Sternenkonstellationen anschaut. Also er kann irgendwo hingucken und kann mehr oder weniger autonom oder zumindest mit ein bisschen Hilfe erkennen, wohin er gerade blickt.
Das ist wieder genau der große Unterschied zu ISO. Bei ISO war es ja so gewesen, dass man tatsächlich mit, ich nenne es jetzt mal, einer großen Kampagne extra so ein Mapping machen von einem gesamten CCD-Ship, die Konstellation runter zur Erde, wird ausgewertet von Flight Dynamics und dann wieder hochschicken. Wenn ISO irgendwann mal durch einen Unfall, Survival Mode, der Computer vom Lage-Regelungssystem ist abgesplitzt oder so was, die Kenntnis verliert, wo er denn gewesen ist, dann muss man diese Prozente neu machen. Das war also, wenn man tatsächlich so einen Survival Mode gehabt hatte, von dem Lage-Regelungssystem von ISO, war es eine große Kampagne, den wieder auf die Reihe zu kriegen. Bei Herschel ist es so, dass der Sternsensor sofort quasi das Ergebnis ausspuckt, ohne diesen Umweg über Ground Processing und dann wieder hochschicken. Das heißt also, der Sternsensor liefert nicht nur eine Information über X und Z in irgendeinem Koordinatensystem von einem Stern und dann das Lage-Regelungssystem muss was Intelligentes draus machen, sondern der Sternsensor sagt selber, ich gucke jetzt in diese Richtung und ich sage dem Satelliten, du bist initial in dieser Position. Du guckst also XYZ in diese Position.
Das heißt, die Elektronik hat auch selber quasi ein komplettes Abbild des Universums aus Blickrichtung von diesem L2-Punkt, aber die ändert sich ja auch laufend. Man hat dann den Umlauf um die Sonne etc.
Nein, der Sternhimmel ist fest. Es ändert sich schon, aber es ändert sich in anderen Dimensionen. Es ändert sich so, dass, was heißt in einer Dimension, der Sternhimmel ändert sich langsam einfach dadurch, dass quasi unser Universum sich dreht, wie wir Teil einer Galaxie sind.
Ich könnte mir da vorstellen, dass jetzt auch diese langsamen Änderungen bei dieser geforderten Präzision nicht unerheblich sind. Oder sind die schon doch unerheblich?
Nein, die sind nicht unerheblich und die spielen da eine Rolle. Man hat nicht ein Abbild von dem gesamten Universum. Das würde natürlich die Fähigkeiten übersteigen.
Dann bräuchte man wahrscheinlich das Teleskop nicht mehr, auch wenn es eh schwer ist, weiß man es.
Sondern man hat einen sogenannten Sternkatalog an Bord. Das sind also ungefähr in der Größenordnung von 4.000, 5.000, ich glaube 4.500 Sterne. Die sind ausgewählte Sterne. Nicht die besonders hell sind. Die haben verschiedene Qualitäten. Wir haben es eben schon angesprochen, wie genau muss ein Sternsensor sein, mit X und Y? Die Genauigkeit erreicht man durch andere Methoden. Es geht darum, dass der Sternsensor so genau wie möglich gemacht wird, indem man also Sterne aussucht, die besonders geeignet sind, um diesen Algorithmus durchlaufen zu lassen. Wenn man jetzt zwei Sterne hintereinander hat, dann gibt es kein kreisrundes Signal mehr, sondern es gibt eine Kombination von zwei Sternen. Wenn man wirklich nur einen Sternenkatalog nehmen würde, wie zum Beispiel den Hipparkus-Sternenkatalog, der alle Sterne auseinanderklappüstern will und genau wissen will, welche Helligkeit hat der Stern, der hinter dem anderen Stern versteckt ist, und das kombiniert ein Signal, dann steht der Sternsensor, das vielleicht nur als ein Signal. Oder als ein Signal, das eine ganz komische Form hat. Verstehe.
Also man nimmt sozusagen nur die, die einem jetzt wirklich die leicht zu erkennen sind und die einem weiterhelfen. Und am Ende geht es ja um, wie viele Sterne von diesen 4.500 kann er mit seinem Ausschnitt so üblicherweise gleichzeitig erfassen? Also so mit diesem, was war das nochmal kurz für einen Ausschnitt? Wie viele Bogensekunden? Also schon ein relativ großer Bereich. Wie viele von diesen 4.500 kommen, werden dann quasi herangezogen?
Einige wenige. Einige wenige. Wir haben verschiedene Modi, das heißt also in der Ordnung von acht, die er dann gleichzeitig prozessieren kann. Wenn er mehr findet, das wird voraus berechnet von Fleiternehmens im Boden. Die sagen also, wenn er jetzt in die Richtung guckt, dann haben wir mehr Sterne im Sichtfeld. Dann kann er auch mehr als acht Sterne nehmen. Und dann machen wir einen zweiten Slot auf. Das heißt, der Satellit tauscht dann also die Bilder aus und berechnet die beiden gleichzeitig. Es sind entweder neun Sterne oder 18 Sterne, die dann nacheinander und dann kombiniert werden, prozessiert werden.
Ok, also relativ wenig werden dann wirklich herangezogen. Das reicht aber trotzdem schon aus, um diese Präzision zu erreichen, unter anderem mit solchen Tricks wie diesem unscharfen Blick, wo man einfach dann die Position auch sehr genau feststellen kann.
Das ist richtig. Also es ist tatsächlich so, die Mathematik oder das Konzept dahinter ist, wenn man in eine Richtung guckt, dann gibt es tatsächlich nur eine Kombination und eine Anordnung von Lichtpunkten, die der Konstellation am Sternenhimmel entspricht. Das ist eindeutig.
Was gehört denn sonst auch in diesem Bus dazu?
Also die Lageregelung war eine wichtige Sache. Zur Lageregelung gehört auch noch dazu, dass wir, man muss unterscheiden, wir sprechen jetzt immer nur von Lageregelung, wohin der Satellite guckt und wohin er gucken soll und wie man dahin kommt. Es gehört auch Bahnregelung dazu und dafür wird auch Düsen benommen als Aktuatoren. Das gehört aber auch zur Lageregelung. Das heißt, wir hatten darüber gesprochen, dass es ein stabiler Orbit ist. Ist es auch für Herschel und den Punkt L2. Man muss aber trotzdem einen gewissen Treibstoff verbrauchen, um auf dieser stabilen Bahn zu bleiben. Weil es gibt halt von außen externe Störungen, wie Sonnenwind. Aber auch da muss man sagen, dass dieses Konzept von einem Orbit um L2 quasi mehr oder weniger brillant ist. Weil wenn man sich einmal auf dieser stabilen Umlaufbahn bewegt, brauchen wir sehr wenig Treibstoff, um auf dieser Bahn zu bleiben. Wir machen vielleicht alle fünf Wochen, alle sechs Wochen, mittlerweile sind wir dazu übergegangen, alle Wochen ein Manöver zu machen, das noch einige Sekunden dauert. Satelliten typischerweise in Erdumlaufbahnen, die auch in anderen Störungsgrößen ausgesetzt sind, wie die Erde ist nicht drunter, sondern die Masseverteilung von der Erde ist unregelmäßig, das sind andere Bahnstörungen, die korrigiert werden müssen, das sind das andere Größen auch noch.
Weil die Erde so eine Kartoffel ist.
Zum Beispiel. Oder auch, wenn sie niedrig fliegen, Erdatmosphäre, die ausgeglichen werden. Der Satellite bremst und muss dann wieder hochgefahren werden. So, Lageregelung und Orbit-Control. Das war also eine wichtige Komponente. Dann andere wichtige Komponente ist das sogenannte On-Board-Data-Handling. Das heißt, sämtliche Telekommunikation an Bord des Satelliten muss irgendwie veraltet werden. Und dieses On-Board-Data-Handling-System sorgt dafür, dass erst mal Telemetrie und Telekommandos verarbeitet werden können, die halt von dem Funksystem kommt. Und wenn ein Telekommando zum Beispiel geschickt wird, das On-Board-Data-Handling von einem Telekommunikationssystem erhält, also wenn der Befehl quasi von der Bodenstation zum Boden gesendet wird, dann ist das On-Board-Data-Handling-System dafür verantwortlich, dass dieses Kommando dahin verteilt wird zu den Adressaten, bei denen es gedacht war. Zum Beispiel die Instrumente oder andere Komponenten von Bus. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Telekommando schicken will, das die Düse feuert, dann muss das ein Telekommando sein, das irgendwie verwaltet wird. Das wird alles durch dieses On-Board-Data-Handling-System. Das On-Board-Data-Handling-System ist zum Beispiel auch dafür verantwortlich, dass Daten aufgenommen werden auf einen Recorder, an Solid-State-Mass-Memory, State-of-the-Art natürlich, sind keine Tapes oder keine Bänder mehr, die sich drehen. Und das sind einmal die Telemetrie des Satelliten selber, des Buses selber, aber natürlich ganz wichtig, fast noch wichtiger, die wissenschaftlichen Messungen, die einen Großteil der Daten machen. Das On-Board-Data-Handling-System ist also verantwortlich, diese Sachen aufzunehmen und auch während des Überflugs dann quasi in einer gewissen Reihenfolge wieder runter zu spielen an Boden.
Wie viel Speicher hat denn das Teil?
Das hat mehrere Gigabit-genaue Nummern, weiß ich nicht.
Und das reicht, um dann so für 24 Stunden die ganzen Beobachtungen abzuspeichern?
Kann man die Rechnung machen. Wir nehmen auf mit 150 Kilobit pro Sekunde für 24 Stunden.
Also 150 Kilobit pro Sekunde war das, ja? Okay, also mal 60 x 60 x 24 Kilobit Gigabit 12 Gigabit.
Das hört sich gut an, ja. Der Mann hat ja ein Rechner, er hat alles im Kopf gemacht.
Ich benutze auch Taschenrechner, aber das ist ja immer die Größenordnung, die wir im Kopf haben, das kriege ich schon noch zusammen. Bits und Beiz habe ich meine Erfahrungen gesammelt. Ja, okay, gut, also er speichert halt alles zwischen und sorgt natürlich für die Kommunikation mit der Bodenstation, klar. Diese ganzen Aufnahmen, die jetzt das Teleskop macht, man will ja effizient sein, man will ja die zur Verfügung stehende Bandbreite zur Erde auch effektiv nutzen. Könnte mir vorstellen, man überträgt jetzt nicht in eigentlichen Sinne Rohdaten, sondern das System bereitet diese Daten auch selber schon so weit auf oder zumindest komprimiert es sie. Das ist halt endlich die Frage. Inwiefern ist das Teleskop jetzt nur so eine Maschine, die einfach Daten liefert oder findet schon eine Vorauswertung oder ein Filtern und eine Redundanz-Kamm statt, der irgendwas schon rausnimmt oder sind die Anforderungen dann zu hoch für so was?
Nee, ich glaube, das würden die Wissenschaftler gar nicht so gerne sehen. Die möchten tatsächlich eher wirklich die Rohdaten haben. Die wollen die Messung haben, so wie sie ist. Die wollen alles Mögliche hinterher machen, indem sie hinterher offline prozessieren.
Nicht, dass sie später feststellen, dass die Software alles falsch gerechnet hat und...
Ja, darauf macht man sich nicht... Verlassen, glaube ich. Was gemacht wird, das wird aber nicht auf dem Level von dem On-Board-Data-Handling-System gemacht, sondern das wird auf dem Level der wissenschaftlichen Instrumente selber gemacht, ist Data Compression, also Komprimieren von Daten. Das sind einfache nachvollziehbare Algorithmen, so wie man Sachen zusammenpackt auf seinem Rechner, ein Zipfile oder so, werden halt Daten reduziert. Verlustfrei. Verlustfrei reduziert, soweit es möglich ist.
Lagerregelung, Bahnregelung, Kommunikation halten mit der Bodenstation, Kommunikation halten mit den Rest des Satelliten. Was macht das System noch weiter aus?
Man muss natürlich auch den Satelliten mit Strom versorgen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt. Für mich unvorstellbar, wie das erreicht wurde. Die Solarzellen versorgen den Satelliten mit Strom. Das ist die Energiequelle, die man nutzt. Man muss sich vorstellen, wir verbrauchen an Bord des Herschel-Satelliten ungefähr 1.100 Watt. Das ist ungefähr so viel wie der Föhn. Das ist der Föhn im Badezimmer. Mit so wenig Energie betreibt man ein System, das tatsächlich diese ganzen wissenschaftlichen Beobachtungen macht. Das ist auch ein System, das aktiv auf fast absolut null Punkt Temperatur kühlt. Ich werde das immer beeindrucken, weil für mich ist das klar, dass man so etwas am Boden machen kann.
Die Kühlung kommt doch nur durch das Helium, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Die Kühlung kommt durch das Helium.
Braucht man dann auch zusätzliche Energie?
Man braucht zusätzliche Energie, um alle Komponenten zu betreiben. Es gibt die passive Kühlung, aber auch das Helium, das quasi am Dampfdruckpunkt betrieben wird. Da haben wir aber zu früh aufgehört. Die wissenschaftlichen Instrumente, die die Beobachtung machen, haben auch noch aktive Kühlung. Bei 1,7 Kelvin sind wir noch gar nicht am Ende. Wenn die Instrumente für die Beobachtung vorbereitet werden, haben sie auch noch Systeme, die bis auf 0,1 Kelvin runterkühlen.
Gibt es noch kälter, eine Rea?
Ich glaube, Planck, die sind noch kälter und machen deswegen auch immer Witze. Irgendjemand hat auch mal gesagt, der kälteste Punkt im Weltraum ist tatsächlich Planck.
Die freuen sich, dass sie die coolsten sind, sozusagen. Das ist schon irgendwie irre. Aber trotzdem muss ja auch erst einmal ein Kilowatt erzeugt werden. Ist das ein Problem?
Nein, das ist kein Problem. Der Satellit ist einfach mal flächenmäßig riesengroß. Der ist sieben Meter hoch. Da muss man halt dieses Schutzschild gegenüber der Sonne aufspannen und pack da einfach Solarzellen drauf. Die ganze Oberfläche ist nicht bedeckt mit Solarzellen. Das ist kein limitierender Faktor für uns. Einfach nur die Energieversorgung ist.
Trotzdem ist es ja immer wichtig, möglichst energiesparend alles zu betreiben.
Das ist richtig. Vor allen Dingen auch, wenn Satelliten länger leben. Manchmal ist es üblicherweise so, wir schalten Satelliten nicht ab. Wenn die nominale Lebensdauer erreicht worden ist, Satelliten zu bauen und hochzuschicken, ist ein riesen Aufwand. Die werden natürlich so lange betrieben, wie sie betrieben werden können. Einer von den limitierenden Faktoren ist auch tatsächlich die Stromversorgung, weil Solarzellen auch degradieren. Die verlieren ihre Eigenschaften.
Das heißt, man braucht eh ein bisschen Spielraum. Es ist besser, wenn man erst mal mehr Energie erzeugen könnte, weil irgendwann funktionieren sie vielleicht nicht mehr so gut und man will das Minimum immer halten können.
Das ist richtig.
Wird das dann schon so spürbar sein nach drei Jahren?
Nein, nein, nein. Wir haben 1.700 Watt momentan und wir brauchen ein bisschen mehr als 1.000 Watt.
Okay, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es daran vielleicht einem scheitert, noch bevor das Helium zu Ende ist, ist gering?
Das ist sehr gering.
Oder fast ausgeschlossen?
Man soll nicht nie sagen, es können Katastrophen passieren, aber die Redundanz an Bord ist halt so, dass wir den Fall quasi ausschließen können.
Sieben Meter ist das Ding lang? Lang, hoch? Ist das ein großer Unterschied in welcher?
Na gut, ich habe jetzt gerade ein Bild im Kopf gehabt, in dem reinen Raum, wo der Satellit zusammengebaut wird und die ganzen kleinen Männchen daneben. Ja, da stand das Ding nach oben. Das größte Verhältnis ist einfach beeindruckend.
Das heißt also, hat sich das Ding entfaltet oder war das so starre?
Gott sei Dank nicht. Mechanische Geschichten sind immer delikat im Weltraum. Die möchte man auch vermeiden. Das Konzept des Satelliten war so, dass man das nicht brauchte. Warum muss ich das so vorstellen? Das war halt diesen Bushauben, über den wir schon geredet haben. Und dann dieses Kühlsystem mit dem Helium. Das ist wie eine Thermosflasche oben drauf. Torus, Tank und oben drauf ist dann dieser Spiegel, 3,5 Meter Durchmesser, der größte Spiegel, der gestartet worden ist.
Der größte Spiegel?
Im Weltraum.
Den es gerade gibt oder den es jemals gab?
Den es jemals gab und den es gerade gibt. Doch auch Herschel ist das größte Weltraumteleskop.
Alles klar. Und Thermoskanal, du hast ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass ganze Geräte oder zumindest Teile davon sind von Anfang an, nachdem sie gebaut wurden, kalt gehalten worden.
Das ist richtig.
Warum? Dass man schon mal testen kann, ob sie diese Kälte halten oder weil sie einfach nur für diese niedrigen Temperaturen überhaupt designt sind und man sich gar nicht an einem anderen Stress aussitzen will?
Nein, weil das System für diese niedrigen Temperaturen designt ist und weil man sich einfach den Zeitaufwand nicht leisten kann, das ständig hoch und runter zu kühlen. Das heißt, wenn man einmal den Aufwand betrieben hat, dann dauert das Wochen, bis der tatsächlich so weit runtergekühlt ist, dass im Inneren dieser Thermosflasche quasi die Temperatur gehalten wird.
Das heißt, auch während der ganze Payload auf der Ariane-Rakete drauf war, wurde die ganze Zeit diese niedrige Temperatur gehalten und während des Starts, das Ding ist also schon quasi in Betriebstemperatur losgeflogen?
Genau. Und das hat man also bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es auf die Rakete gesetzt hat, hat man das alles erreichen können. Das ist ja klar, man kann jederzeit ran. Man hat da Ventile und Schläuche, die da reingehen und so weiter. Und dann musste dieses Kühlsystem halt quasi für eine gewisse Zeit autonom einfach die Temperatur halten können, um halt diesen Zeitpunkt auf die Ariane draufpacken und den Weltraumschießen zu überbrücken. Und bevor man dann also quasi starten konnte, das cryogene System in Betrieb zu nehmen im Weltraum, wie es geplant ist, musste das System die Temperatur selber halten. Das war eine sehr delikate Angelegenheit und war ein sehr spannender Moment, gerade auch während des Starts. Wir sprechen von kurzen Zeitraum. Das Kühlsystem, das sind Ventile und irgendwelche Pipelines, damit dieser Fluss gewährleisten kann, wie zwischen Zwiebelhäuten, wo dann Leitungen zwischendrin sind, bis es nach außen geht, weil die Temperatur immer schrittweise reduziert wird, bis man diese Außentemperatur erreichen kann. Das waren also Geschichten, die noch während des Starts gemacht werden mussten und die auch nicht unter unserer Kontrolle waren. Weder Bodenkontrolle, als der Satelliten noch zusammengebaut war. Die haben da mit dem Schalter umgelegt, bevor die Rakete gestartet worden ist. Das musste gemacht werden, bevor wir Kontakt hatten mit dem Satelliten. Das waren also fest installierte Telekommandos, die von der Ariane-Oberstufe an den Satelliten geschickt wurden. Das war also ein genauer Zeitplan. Nach so und so vielen Minuten musste da ein Ventil geöffnet werden. Und wenn das nicht geschehen wäre, dann wäre dieser Fluss nicht in Gang gekommen. Und das Ganze hätte nicht funktioniert. Das war ein sehr spannender Moment. Das war also nachdem der Start, ich weiß nicht, ob man sich das vorstellen kann, im Kontrollraum, man sieht die großen Bildschirme, Ariane startet. Und dann hat man ungefähr 12 Minuten Zeit, bis der Satellit abgetrennt ist und tatsächlich an einer Bodensstation vorbeikommt, dass man das erste Signal empfangen kann.
Das ist dann der Moment der Befreiung?
Das war dann der Moment der Befreiung. Nicht nur üblicherweise wie bei anderen Missionen, wo man tatsächlich die erste Telemetrie sieht und sieht, aha, wir haben jetzt hier einen Satelliten. Der schickt Telemetrie, also ist er in Ordnung. Und er ist auch abgetrennt, separiert. Man sieht den Separation Step, separated. Sondern das erste, worauf wir geguckt haben, sind diese Ventile aufgegangen. Es gab auch keine Möglichkeit, mit einer Prozedur das wieder zu retten. Wenn diese Ventile nicht aufgegangen wären, dann wäre es das gewesen. Das waren sehr spannende Momente. Dann gucken wir auf die Bildschirme und sehen, wir haben Telemetrie. Aber die Ventile sind auf und dann große Erleichterung.
Zwei Steine auf einmal, die da vom Herzen fallen.
Von wegen Entfalten. Wie gesagt, so Sachen wie komplizierte Strukturen entfalten, das ist immer ein Delikat, haben wir Gott sei Dank nicht gehabt. Eine Sache hatten wir gehabt. Nach einer gewissen Zeit, nachdem der Satellit im Weltraum war, wir mussten warten, bis verschiedene Komponenten sich genug runtergekühlt hatten, bis wir tatsächlich erlauben konnten, dass Infrarotlicht auf die Instrumente fällt. Das heißt, das Einzige, was beweglich war an dem Satelliten und was wir quasi ausfalten mussten, ist nichts anderes als diese Thermoskanne zu öffnen. Das war also ein Mechanismus da, der oben diese Thermoskanne aufgemacht hat. Nicht, damit das Helium rauskommt, sondern man muss sich das als Thorustank vorstellen, also als runden Tank, der quasi rund um den Gang der Strahlen gebaut ist. Das heißt also, durch den Spiegel muss dann ins Zentrum von diesem Tank Licht reinfallen können. Und das war auch ein großer Moment, dass man halt tatsächlich diesen Tankdeckel dann aufgemacht hat, weil das war auch ein Teil, das, wie gesagt, zwei Jahre vor dem Start zum letzten Mal betrieben worden ist. Seitdem war das Ding zu, am Boden war das immer zu. Die Instrumente waren innen drin integriert. Der Tankdeckel oben war zu.
In zwei Jahren lagen diese Geräte einfach da so drin, bei einer Mod-Scale sozusagen.
Vor allem dieser Deckel, der dann aufgehen muss. Das ist auch ein Mechanismus, der dann gut getestet sein will und so weiter. Und das war auch ein großer Moment, wo wir dann tatsächlich diesen Deckel aufgemacht haben und das erste Mal Licht tatsächlich auf den Detektor von einem von den Instrumenten fallen konnte.
Ist das eigentlich auch ein Problem, wenn man jetzt solche super niedrigen Temperaturen auf der Erde erzeugt und das quasi die ganze Zeit so vorhält? Ich meine, da darf da ja dann quasi auch kein Wasser rankommen. War das dann so im Vakuum gehalten? Nicht, dass sich da einspältet oder sonst irgendwas?
Nein, nicht im Vakuum. Aber in einem ganz normalen Reihenraum. Das sind diese Integrationsräume, die üblicherweise verschiedene Anforderungen haben müssen. Und das reicht auch. Das Problem hat sich so für Herschel eigentlich nicht gestellt, dass man da vielleicht kontaminiert wäre oder so. Was nicht war, ist für die Spiegel. Also wir haben zwei Spiegel. Wir haben den großen 3,5-Meter-Spiegel und dann noch einen zweiten Spiegel, der das Signal dann rundum lenkt wieder. Und da war es tatsächlich so, dass während dieser Zeit, wo wir den Satelliten also quasi sich abkühlen lassen haben. Also der Satellit war auf der Arianooberstufe und hatte dann Temperaturen wie Kuhu sind, keine Ahnung, 25, 30 Grad.
Auch schön feuchter alles.
Drinnen war es schon 1,7 Kelvin, aber die anderen Komponenten außenrum, die waren natürlich höherer Temperatur. Feucht nicht, wir waren ja im Reihenraum. Man musste also langsam warten, bis die Temperatur sich passiv runterkühlt. Und einige Komponenten, die Spiegel, musste man absichtlich stoppen, diesen Kühlprozess. Das heißt, man hat also auf einer gewissen Temperaturstufe dann tatsächlich Heizkörper eingeschaltet, um eine gewisse Zeit lang abzuwarten, dass irgendwelche Sachen, die auf dem Spiegel kondensiert wären, verdampfen zu lassen. Und dann, nach einigen Tagen, konnte man diese Heizung abschalten und dann konnte die Temperaturen an den Spiegeln weiter runter sich abkühlen, bis es dann zu dem Zeitpunkt gekommen ist, wo wir dann tatsächlich gesagt haben, so, das Infrarotlicht, das jetzt also quasi...
Das heißt, die Instrumente waren alle schon gut gekühlt und sind fertig versiegelt, im Kältezustand nach oben befördert worden, aber alles andere außerhalb dieses Tanks musste dann halt schon noch nachgekühlt werden, damit es eben die entsprechende Betriebstemperatur hat.
Genau. Also nicht aktiv nachgekühlt werden, sondern man hat einfach gewartet, bis es sich abkühlt. Bis es sich abkühlt, so wie es vorgesehen ist. Wie gesagt, ganz am Anfang können wir die Bogen schließen, die Sonne scheint auf das Schutzschelt, aber die Rückseite des Satelliten ist einfach dadurch, dass keine Strahlung drauf hält und ständig dann, wenn Strahlung abgestrahlt wird, erreicht dann irgendwann Gleichgewicht.
Wir wollten uns ja hier in diesem Gespräch vor allem um den Satelliten selber hier drehen, weil das ist ja jetzt auch deine Expertise, bisher nicht Teil des wissenschaftlichen Teams, was jetzt eben wirklich mit Herschel was anstellt. Trotz alledem wollte ich so zum Schluss nochmal drauf kommen, das Einzige, was ja jetzt im Prinzip noch offen ist, ist, was die Infrarot-Weltraumteleskop-Weltraumteleskop in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA, in der USA.
Die Wäldenlänge, die die Detektoren halt vermessen können, sind im Infrarotenbereich. Und das kann man sich auch vorstellen, keine Ahnung, wie Bilder, die erzeugt werden, natürlich nicht im sichtbaren Bereich. Also die Bilder, Herschel hat wunderbare Bilder gemacht, wie man sie vielleicht auch nur von Hubble kennt. Aber man muss sich immer im Hinterkopf behalten, das sind natürlich keine echten Farben, sondern das ist nur ein Abbild von der Verteilung der Intensität verschiedener Wellenlängen im infraroten Bereich.
Damit wir uns das anschauen können, dann in den sichtbaren Bereich überführt werden.
Genau, das sind diese spektakulären Bilder, das nennt man Fotometrie. Es wird dann auch Spektometrie betrieben. Spektometrie heißt, gewisse Wellenlängen werden absorbiert von gewissen Elementen. Das heißt, man kann also rauskriegen, was befindet sich da jetzt zum Beispiel. Ich gucke jetzt gerade irgendwie in eine Staubwolke. Was ist die Verteilung von Kohlenmonoxid? Was ist die Verteilung von Wasser? Was finde ich da? Dass es dann in der Spektometrie betrieben wird. Das Interessante hierbei ist, dass man in ganz simplen Worten einfach Gegenstände oder Dinge, Galaxien, Sternenstaub, in einem anderen Licht sieht. Das Interessante für Astronomen ist das Vergleichen oder vergleichbare Beobachtungen zu machen. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel eine entfernte Galaxie beobachtet und würde da intensive Signale Infraroten sehen, was dann aussieht, als ob da Sonn wäre, das ist aber gar nicht im sichtbaren Reich, wären das Staubwolken oder es wäre ein dunkler Fleck auf einem normalen Bild. Da bedeutet das für Astrodome, dass da eine hohe Aktivität ist im Sinne von Sternengeburten. Wenn man eine hohe Intensität hat, Beobachtungen im Röntgenbereich, die das Athlet XMM macht, ist das vielleicht ein Anzeichen dafür, dass gerade Sterne explodieren oder Sterne zum Ende ihres Lebens kommen. Diese ganzen Geschichten, wie entstehen Sonnensysteme, werden in diesem Sinne erforscht, indem man versucht, die Modelle, die man hat von unserem Universum, wie entsteht so etwas, wie entsteht eine Galaxie, abzugleichen mit den Signalen, die man empfängt. Eine andere Geschichte ist, wir gucken uns nicht nur entfernte Galaxien an, sondern wir gucken uns auch Objekte an in unserem Sonnensystem, Asteroiden. Da gab es auch sehr interessante Ergebnisse. Wie gesagt, ich bin kein Wissenschaftler, ich kann das auch nur wiedergeben mit den Worten eines allein. Bei ISO war es eine ganz große Attraktion, dass man tatsächlich Wasser gefunden hat in irgendwelchen unerwarteten Gegenden. Wir sind angeguckt oder Asteroiden oder Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem und haben dann gerufen, wir finden Wasser. Wasser ist Hinweis oder eine Voraussetzung zum Leben. Nachdem das angefangen hat, hat es nie wieder aufgehört. Jetzt finden wir Wasser überall. Das wird auch mit Herschel bestätigt. Das sind also Sachen, die auch für mich als Laien, obwohl ich es nicht verstehe, sehr interessant sind. Zum Beispiel die Geschichte, wo kommt das Wasser her, das wir auf der Erde haben? Dann sind Beobachtungen gemacht worden von einem Asteroiden. Man wollte die Verteilung des Wassers, das auf diesem Asteroiden vermutet wird, es gibt verschiedene Derivate von Wasser, Wasserstoffatomen, ob die Verteilung ähnlich ist wie die des Wassers auf der Erde. Man hat das bestätigt. Es gibt mehr oder weniger die Bestätigung, dass das Wasser, das wir hier auf der Erde haben, die Ozeane, dieses Wasser aus dem Weltraum kommt und durch Kometen, Asteroiden, die auf die Erde gestürzt sind, hier zu dieser Erde gelangt ist. Nur ein paar Wochen später kam diese Meldung von Beobachtung, dass man ein Sonnensystem, das gerade im Begriff ist, zu entstehen beobachtet hat. Quasi eine Sonne in der Mitte und eine Staubscheibe drum herum. Und auch wieder bestätigt hat, dass da in einigen Ringen ein hoher Anteil Wasser ist. Und sehr wahrscheinlich wird sich das wiederholen. Die innere Ringe bilden dann Planeten. Die äußeren Ringe bilden vielleicht Asteroiden, die dann irgendwann mal herabregnen auf diese Planeten und da vielleicht Ozeane bilden können. So stellt sich das für mich als Laie da. Wie gesagt, ich bin kein Experte. Neben meinem Job, dass ich diesen Satelliten da fahre und betreibe, blickt man immer mit großem Interesse auf die Rückmeldung der Community. Ja, mit großem Interesse und mit großem Staunen.
Was ich dir vielleicht auch darstellt, dann indirekt ist ja auch, wie ist denn das Projekt in der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinde angekommen? Hat es die Erwartungen erfüllt? War das so, wie man sich das gedacht hatte?
Also die Rückmeldung, die wir bekommen, die ich teilweise durch meine Kollegen bekomme in der ESOC, in einem Astronomy-Center bei Matret, in Vierfranckheim, das sind die Leute, mit denen wir kommunizieren, die uns quasi die Kommandos für die Instrumente liefern. Wir sind verantwortlich für diesen Bus, und die sind dafür verantwortlich, wie diese Instrumente betreiben. Und wir haben natürlich Regenaustausch, und wir fragen auch ab und zu, und könnte uns mal was, was ich material schicken, dass wir dann ein bisschen im Team interne Präsentationen machen und so. Und so, wie sich das darstellt und so, wie das durch die Presse geht, ist Herschel also ein Riesenerfolg und hat alle Erwartungen übertroffen. Also das ist, Europa, Weltraum ist natürlich keine Nation, aber die Europa als Weltraum betreibende Entität braucht sich hinter niemandem verstecken. Und das sieht man auch, also das ist ja quasi ein Service. Also Herschel ist ein Teleskop. Und es wird den Astronomen aus der ganzen Welt zur Verfügung gestellt. Das heißt, es gibt also dann Kampagnen, wo Vorschläge für Beobachtungen quasi ausgeschrieben werden. Also wer möchte irgendwas beobachten? Das geht weltweit, das ist weltweit offen. Und alle Astronomen rund um die Welt benutzen dieses Teleskop Herschel, um ihre Beobachtungen zu machen.
Das ist natürlich eine einmalige Position von einem einmaligen Teleskop, was es so bisher so noch nicht gegeben hat.
Es regnet Publikationen.
Bleibt spannend, auch das letzte anderthalb Jahr noch. Ja Micha, wenn wir nichts super Wichtiges vergessen haben, haben wir, haben wir bestimmt, oder? Würde ich das jetzt mal zum Ende führen für das Gespräch, sage ich vielen Dank.
Danke auch.
Den Einblick hier in die Technik des Herschel-Weltraumteleskops. Mal schauen, ob wir hier auch noch die Gelegenheit finden, vielleicht den Planck auch noch mal näher zu begutachten, beziehungsweise auch die andere Seite, nämlich die wissenschaftliche Ausbeute, hier noch weiter zu vertiefen. Aber an der Stelle machen wir jetzt zumindest erstmal Schluss. Und ja, ich bedanke mich auch wieder mal fürs Zuhören. Das war Raumzeit, die 29. Ausgabe. Weiter geht es mit der 30 und mit der 31 und mit der 32 und so weiter.